here we are baby
it's monday
september 27th
yes sir
uh september 27th boy
it's such a boomer thing to say but like
can you believe september is already
over oh my god every year is just
shorter and shorter right every year is
so short
it's all the spell cuz
well you were playing on the boomer
thing like you know what is spill kiss
bilkis is like yiddish for all it's like
[ __ ]
oh yeah all the spill kiss yeah
okay
i'll buy it
thank you guys for being here as always
you know i'm really happy
feeling good this monday
uh
sponsored by
honeystamps.com hello fresh and policy
genius boy do we love them thank you
you know i'm feeling good
i came in late because you know
[Applause]
theodore stuff and
final fantasy stuff i'll be honest too
it's like i finished playing at two and
i'm like okay i'm gonna go to bed and
then theodore always wakes up at two
and last night he really he wanted to
come into our bedroom
and get in the bed with us and then it
turns into a whole game for him
he's cute though good kid
very happy with how the leftovers uh
was being was being uh received very
happy with that yeah we launched finally
the new show with hassan
and uh i'm really happy you know
i thought it was fun
and i'm looking forward to making more
episodes i mean there's just so much
great content out there from the
right wing infosphere
i think we covered about
20 percent of our
yeah it's like
and it was three hours long so and there
was one i think we should save it for
next week because it's so good but
crowders uh steven crowder's take on the
black james bond uh yes i was like oh
man that was ugh it's so good i'm gonna
save it though so yeah we'll talk about
that on uh this week's episode but here
we are h3 tv
we got calls lined up we got buzzers
we got everything to talk about
if you guys want to call in you can call
in at 1 808 is that right hot meme
number 808 hot mean people we'll do it
live
if you want to call in
talk about something go ahead but you
might get you might get buzzed so i'm
warning you with peace and love
there was uh don't take it personally we
just we need the show must must move
forward
did you just do a buzzer i didn't hear a
sound
yeah i didn't hear it either
yeah i did i don't know didn't hear it
go ahead give it a spies have i lost my
privileges there it is uh you lost your
sound maybe huh let's see
you gotta go i hope you got it
okay
decided to keep the godfather sound
after oh play a lot of debate
oh my god
you left it in did you yeah it's just
trying to bait me now the the
minute we ended uh last monday
i'm like all right i have the new file
and they're like no no keep it keep it
zach was genuinely very distressed about
it i know i saw him after the show and
zach and he was really down and i was
like zach it's all good buddy it's just
we're just goofs yeah it's just goofs
he's a perfectionist what can you say
just want to do a good job yeah you do a
great job you do a great job thank you i
do do
you do do a great job
so um also a happy exciting announcement
h3 movie has been cast
this is a post from the subreddit
and when our life story is ready to be
told i will be played by chris pratt
just like mario himself of course chris
pratt's the leading man you know we look
a lot alike so it makes sense you look a
lot like uh
sir around like the second season of
parks and rec
i'll take it dude any any comparison to
chris brad i'll take man
still a compliment yeah definitely ela
played by gaga i love this movie
this is totally what hollywood do if
they made like hi guys if they made like
a biopic
they always they take it too damn far
it's like all of a sudden i'm a handsome
movie star
either is a beautiful movie star but
gaga for some reason you know
ela's like a great singer all of a
sudden
[Laughter]
she's like singing when i die
this one i like dan i'm sorry but i you
know you say i'm sorry and then i saw
people in the comments saying they did
dan dirty
i [ __ ] love paul gmail i think he's
one of the best actors alive i i was not
insulted by this at all i think the
reason people assume you've done dirty
by this is because his role he was a
howard's uh producer in private parts
and he played the producer he hates that
he called pig vomit oh i didn't even
make that connection yeah because he
looks like a pig and he makes you want
to vomit right of course yeah yeah he
was great in that movie yeah everything
but i i think this is a great role yeah
of course ian none other than ryan
gosling
that that's very
highest compliment ever i'm a huge papa
goss fan
are they oh papagos with peace and love
adam scott was a big oversight here
don't take this away from me adam scott
i'd seen if you guys don't know he's the
guy from parks and recs right
yeah and i thought that was pretty good
but i think yeah i mean ian i'm sorry
but this is a miscast
no no no no no yeah i'm not sure
i'm sorry yeah well i'm chris pratt so
he has a massive penis
chat is saying you have a better
hairline than chris pratt do i you
definitely do
oh what the [ __ ] [ __ ] look at your
receding ass hair he cannot play me
find an a-list actor with a good
hairline who's out there
i mean let's be honest is there an
a-list celebrity with a hairline like
this
george clooney has a good hairline right
and good like gray hairs and stuff uh
certainly
maybe george clooney should play me
you know i searched celebrity with the
best hairline and it just comes up with
celebrities with the best hair
transplants it just redirects that's
what i'm saying
you know uh george lucas uh possibly i
just leading man i just googled
celebrities with the best hairline and
it just came up you so
yeah
did it really because we need to work on
that seo we need to write an article
about celebrities with the best hairline
so i show up first
anyway mcconaughey is pretty strong
hairline
i'm like i'm just looking through some
a-listers doesn't compare to ethan's
though i'm not honestly all right fair
enough let's get some howdy skill you
know yeah
we're gonna have to
well we'll do some hollywood magic on
that hairline because that's way too far
back people saying tom cruise yeah
that's true tom cruise's hairline for
his age
tom cruise pretty strong we get some
action scenes going in there
running really gatsby some intense
gatsby shots
zach of course played by i don't know
his name but he's this dude jason mamoa
yeah it's so funny i think it was the
first
time bobby lee was on he called me a low
rent jason momoa that's right he didn't
say that that's no compliment it is a
compliment yeah even at the low rent
it's still a couple yeah yeah
yeah i love how this is turning into
like a marvel movie
uh uh what do you think about pete
davidson for you ab
uh first time it was a romy
what
malek
you prefer rami malik or uh i prefer
ravi malik i think really
yeah definitely
pete's cooler than romney makes me feel
good about my weird ass big eyes
where you're i don't you make such a
hubble about your eyes your eyes are not
that weird maybe it's just my cousins
teasing me growing up but i
yeah i don't know
people think romney's sexy so i'll take
it
it's a [ __ ] oscar i take pete i take
pete
apparently people just want to [ __ ] a
lot of people in the chat saying mark
ruffalo i'm assuming that's another
suggestion for the hairline thing
because airline's pretty good oh mark
ruffalo yeah but he's not a leading man
so i can't allow him to play me
he's the freaking hulk yeah but yeah
it's not the same he's i need a chris
pratt a tom cruise okay dude i'm looking
up all these they don't compare tom
cruise mark ruffalo
i'm looking at every every name we're
throwing out that's what i'm saying
no leading man in all of hollywood has a
hairline this good
and it's all i've got so you know um
this is a great one love i mean uh tom
hardy wow
is it really
that's who you got
there we go if you say so i don't see
their symptoms i think it said the lips
and the lips yeah it's the fat lips
for sure thank you for life
olivia got cast i don't i have no idea
who this is okay so we were talking
about it before the show olivia knew who
it was and apparently it's just like
somebody on season two of like dance
moms or something
why'd they give her something that's
like we're all like where's olivia by
the way she's upstairs screaming the
phone calls oh right yeah
i believe it's teen mom or teen mom she
said she just she's getting this one in
the team i don't know we could do
[ __ ] for her that's an insult
definitely and uh the addams family girl
i forget her name but come on i mean but
that's a great cast for sam max the
reach man that's christina the richie
the reach what is the reach the reach
what does that mean christina ricci is
her name oh the reach yeah
sam didn't even know who she was and it
like that like bro oh well that broke my
heart
adam's family
20 years ago
there it is guys the h3 movie
the truth the true story
i think george lucas
is our guy
he's the only one with a good hairline
oh interesting he's not an actor can i
put something forward about george lucas
he's got a weird hairline though
like he's got a good hairline
but a weird hairline
like
i don't know man that's pretty [ __ ]
strong
it's too far down his forehead
that's what's tricky about having the
good hair line if it's too low it can be
a little weird i think this is okay
though you like it how does he do it i
mean this is unbelievable i'm more
interested in his that's why that looks
pretty good i'm not going to hate him
yeah
how does he's not an actor though so it
doesn't quite work excuse me he was in
revenge of the sith as one some big blue
[ __ ] alien oh what's he yeah okay
he's flattering he's using the force to
keep it this look at this flattering uh
caricature of our boy he's got [ __ ] in
here
his neck his neck fupa is the same size
as his face
so oddly enough i was looking that up
this weekend about his neck fupa and
it's rumored that he may have uh some
disease that's causing it but oh i don't
know i don't know if it's confirmed i
was going to say he's not he's got he's
got a bigger neckline than the damn
[ __ ] great plains of america
he kissed his old nasty pig stinking
neck
what
anyway uh vin diesel will play shredder
right
top comm right there and that that's a
good cat definitely yeah
talk to me baby
the rock as alfredo yeah
shaping up to be a pretty interesting
film
yeah and then there was a follow-up that
was just posted like an hour or two ago
that has some good stuff as well yeah
the supporting test
some people that were left out
where it's right under that oh right got
it
let's see
oh no more okay okay all right
oh wow the whole h3 universe keanu
reeves cameron very nice yeah i love
keanu as just like a secondary character
in our blockbusters that's just how big
it
is my mom is played by
yo this lady has got more drip than
[ __ ] lil wayne it's diane keaton the
kids dude the kids is this from a movie
what's with the drip no i think she's
just at a note ward
something it's the kids dude my dad is
played by you know stephen king of
course
this is a really good cast it's hard
it's ryan cavanaugh played by harvey
weinstein right or vice versa i'm
actually not sure what they're trying to
indicate there but keemstar played by
charlie day
you know what maybe we should play
keemstar by r kelly i know like it's the
he's keemstar is not black although he
does say he's 10 black well
unfortunately as of like an hour ago i
don't think archaic is going to be
available well listen i don't think
harvey weinstein's available either good
point
good point
i got
crowder
yeah i think we're gonna have a hard
time casting crowd or nobody's gonna
play that role james gordon you don't
think he'd take cats he'll take anything
take anything
humber dean
bro
hassan is being played by this meatloaf
from star wars adam driver
ben swolo oh this is good trisha by
danny devito
i don't hate that i mean there's some
logic there might be the best casting in
this whole thing there's some logic to
that
you know
matt hoss played by this guy
whoever that is okay
we love it thank you thank you
fun little thought experiment there yep
you know i saw a video of grand rising
or uh there's no such thing as a
coincidence guy called into the show
friend of the show william knight
and man he's stepping up his [ __ ] boy
because i noticed his views were kind of
dipping a little bit
i think the shtick was wearing off a
little bit
and the problem too is that he was i
think he's trying too hard to go
mainstream and he's kind of giving up on
the stuff that we all love him for like
mermaids and he doesn't talk about
merman anymore
and and and that's just not that's just
not going to get him far
merman erasure
it's [ __ ] up
um h3 movie here's chris pratt with my
hairline
let's see what do you guys think
scary looking
way better and
they should make him like mario oh he's
a little thicker he's got my shirt on
interesting
[Laughter]
okay i can see it sure fantastic
so anyway grand rising he's so cool
he is
chris pratt as mario man
but anyway um here his is his latest
video and i'm like this [ __ ] is
back on his [ __ ] as most of you know
words cast spells everything you write
say and think those look pretty good too
like that's how high budget
whenever you sign your name on something
you are energetically binding a part of
yourself to that document like a horcrux
use this knowledge to your advantage
whenever you're doing manifesting
activities like creating a vision board
or scripting
sign your name at the bottom
if you use affirmations use your name
this will alert your subconscious mind
that whatever you're saying is true
and about you
try it in the comments yeah where do you
get wings like that with your name in it
william knight loves to seem to be
sprouting from his shoulder blades and i
think those are real right download my
app grand rising territory look at the
top comment after me yeah he's in his
final boss form that's absolutely right
it's like the the phase two with final
fantasy boss
right
i didn't wake up
yeah but those wings are disturbingly
real like where do you get those bruh
someone googled that [ __ ] well
they look pretty good i think they're
real okay as most of you know
words cast i i wasn't able to oh
oh this was just spliced in okay let's
watch it
[Music]
okay i'm out no i think it just
it's just tick tock
actually wanted to go to his um page
because oh here he has more more wings
oh a dog okay interesting it is no
coincidence that dog spilled backwards
is god
you see canine angels
wow he really went there huh
i can't believe it he really unlocked
i've never noticed that before
also what's interesting about that is
that it's true for all languages all
languages dog is god backwards that's
how you know it's real yeah it's right
right like how do you say dog in spanish
there's no [ __ ] that came out
with that [ __ ] i mean i thought thought
it was that but i didn't want to be
wrong so i was i was scared so pero
backwards is orep which means god in
spanish
everybody knows that there's no such
thing as the coincidence in arabic is
kelp
so here let's let's get on with that
though we're sent to planet earth to
help raise its frequency
i believe dogs are humans actually
understand patience forgiveness and
unconditional love
three characteristics of god's valid
consciousness i believe i actually agree
we should all attain to achieve
affirm this
the god-living energy that i radiate
comes back to me tenfold
it is no coincidence
yeah i i'm actually okay we found the
wings this is it is that it
um it looks pretty similar plasticky
like his were actually more genuine
feather
don't you agree it looks that one looks
more like a cape
all right i mean i've been trying to
tell you that real but you you seem to
be blowing past that
no i'm not i mean i acknowledge it i
just commented on all angles words
you think that's it i mean it looks
pretty similar it's
380 i mean that's
that's not bad for sure it's a request
to the universe
[Music]
okay well we have to consider the fact
that they are real as well
you know
let's not blow him out entirely wake up
um
380 huh might need to get me a pair of
that to be honest
i think i might need a pair of those bro
i adding to cart now yeah add to cart
please here's another grand rising
when did you lose your excitement about
life
when did you stop
dancing
today's message
yeah there's straight up cultists in the
background brah
to your childlike perspective
get excited we got people on robes the
peeling back in the trees
the more you focus on the little
miracles
the more you attract the bigger ones
wait does he like a baby
that's a baby go back to your child-like
perspective with that kid dude well yeah
he's definitely gonna sacrifice it for
for good for good vibes
where are you getting these kids
[Music]
you know it no longer matters at all
what he's saying it's all just about the
environment
that's all that matters in his videos
now
that's what makes him pop off it's like
this crazy scenario like let's see
well he got so much attention for the
one with the jogger uh getting scared or
whatever maybe he realized that you need
these little easter eggs absolutely here
this one is three million let's see what
happens yep there is no such thing as
kneeling in the background the fact that
you're watching this video means you are
energetically aligned with me and this
with me and this baby i'm about to dig a
hole for
your depression is a result of
unmonitored thoughts and overthinking a
psychological fact bro are you sure you
want to be putting that out there
you got credentials to be putting
forward that kind of [ __ ] confirm this
today i choose to be happy for no reason
a positive mindset likes all of my
thoughts memories and experiences his
eyes are so white
it's pretty amazing there is no such
thing as a coincidence he's doing
filters on his eyes how are they so
white i'll stop this oh god oh my god
oh my god what is happening
i gotta get out of here
gotta get out of here he does have
he does have really intense eyes i don't
i don't think it is a filter maybe maybe
contacts for the
virus oh you know what i think when you
i've heard this um when you
drain the blood of a baby you can use it
like eye droppers
in your eyes you hear that music coming
in there's no such thing as a dead baby
gun to waste he does have his own filter
on instagram i don't know if
he's using it but i think he said on our
podcast that he used to filter if i
remember oh he has a white eye filter
that's a relief no it's more like a gold
twilight eye
there's no such thing as a coincidence
the fact that you're watching this video
right now
means that you will be eating mexican
food tonight nachos to be specific how
many people are going to get stuff
like i'm actually energetically aligning
myself the fact that you're watching
this right now means that you will get
nachos with shredded chicken cheese
guacamole sour cream beans
and salsa
there's no such thing as a coincidence
[Music]
oh wake up
the fact that you're watching this right
now
means that it's monday september 27th
there's no such thing as a coincidence
no actually that's not true you might be
watching this tomorrow
should we watch more grand rising pretty
captivated by him real quick somebody
donated a hundred and fifty dollars oh
my goodness thank you said towards that
three million dollar bunkle bunk bunker
oh my goodness goodness thank you so
much eat your heart out
yeah i am
i am way down is going to take me so
long to recoup though from that set yeah
we're going to be here for i don't think
i'll take it
from that set i'm never going to recover
financially from this
um somebody else donated 20 bucks and
said i'm dead broke but really this cast
makes me happy i guess some reference to
the
commercial donation cass 20 bucks dude
if you're depressed yeah i'm rich as
[ __ ] you know that i'm rich
we appreciate it and i don't want to
make it sound like we're not going to
first of all thank you for the thought i
appreciate it i do but i just want to
tell everyone like you know i'm rich i
don't need the money like it's nice and
i appreciate it it's but like seriously
take care of yourself yeah come on the
show is free
just watch the ads that's it peace and
love
[Applause]
but thank you i mean i do thank you so
much i really do appreciate it thank you
um
let's see if there's one more we can get
here that's good dude you got to put the
babies away though
you can't be using babies as props in
your videos
somebody's kid man
this one has six million damn what am i
missing out on roll it
with all this talk about the screaming
oh and my lack of reaction you're
probably wondering what happened to the
woman and why did i choose to upload it
a wise man once said
the major problem of life is learning
how to deal with costly interruptions
today's message who said that google
that i don't know who said that you'd be
like adolf hitler
you never know i'm not i'm just saying
here
it is probably one of these things where
he's quoting himself
a wise man once said
the problem is somebody's got on that
oh no
no dude
interrupt it
tell me what who said it
well that's not what i'm annoying he's
googling i'm just i gotta tell you i
gotta warn you
what the [ __ ] we're in the same forest
we're in the grand rising forest rising
from the swamp no such thing as a
coincidence
oh no
we're in the grand rising forest
[ __ ] i'm saying mlk said that oh okay
okay we like okay not adolf hitler we
stand
up i'm okay i mean i'm okay i almost
said hate off but
do not stand up we do not stand
[Music]
wow wow wow wow
wow wow we
yes so anyway moving on our kelly
is going to prison who's surprised
i
mean these courtroom drawings are pretty
epic hasn't he how long has he already
been in jail for like a year or two
yeah that means he's going to get out of
jail though only 10 years he can be out
like we'll tend to life
tend to life i mean he has they haven't
sentenced him yet oh yeah
no he was just found guilty the
sentencing will happen in a few weeks
got it
yeah i remember one of the prosecutors
said or i saw this quote they said it's
one of the worst cases
of trafficking i've ever seen or
whatever
so i don't have a fault i tried it as a
racketeering case which i guess is
was
a very unconventional way to pass
[Laughter]
[Music]
do you have your passports did you get
your shots
[Music]
[Music]
you think anyone's gonna be doing
conjugal visits for our kelly i hope
they don't allow that
you know that there's gonna be people
coming in for it though
not all states do that from what i
understand what the [ __ ] actually is a
conjugal visit like is what it sounds
like is it the visit for the purpose of
having sex with your spouse
to visit with your spouse and pride in
private and so i mean that happened
yeah
do not come i don't see any reason why
prisoners shouldn't be allowed to
have be intimate with their
yeah i only said he shouldn't because
he's a sex criminal he's an insane sex
criminal no i'm not opposed to that
being allowed every week every week a
new young girl coming and calling him
daddy for a conjugal vision
hi i'm dick tip
by the way this [ __ ] was
arrested new york so it's in new york
right he was on trial in new york
or was it in chicago
anyways california connecticut new york
and washington are the only four states
that allow conjugal visits which which
states california connecticut new york
and washington
so most states don't honestly in my
opinion all
i think well yeah maybe there's an
exception for sex criminals but like
obviously you have to someone has to
want to come there and be with you but
like
um
it's this a lot disallowing prisoners
are people i mean you know it's it's
insane how prisoners in america are
treated you know
right no i i agree
but anyway actually
and in fact because it says
in the united states there
it's just like a few hours i'm seeing
really quick in a lot of other countries
it's um
significantly more than that in france
inmates are permitted control visits
visits last up to 72 hours and take
place in a mini apartment consisting of
two small rooms a kitchen and dining
area whoa i want that for myself now i'm
not even prisoner
that sounds nice
69. they could provide supplies such as
soap condoms lubricant bed linens and
towels 72-hour
well it's cited
oh it is cited because i was reading off
the wikipedia page for conjugal visits
but i decided from the bbc news i
believe it you know if you go to europe
scandinavia in particular i've seen
shout out to love
still recovering from the [ __ ] oh
yeah throat's still [ __ ] up there's
just so much mucus backed up there what
were you saying dan
oh just yeah those swedish prisons are
nicer than my apartment
well that's not true
and worse or better i guess finland you
don't even have to spend the day there
you just have to spend them just check
in
you literally check in at a certain time
at night the thing is i'm i'm actually a
huge
advocate for the kind of prisons you see
in in uh i just
they're playing vr prison and this is
the first image was a dude playing some
vr
the truth is that
you know you americans if you
try to make a point dan
thank you
sorry
the point is that when you take away
people's humanity
then then then
which is what you see in american
systems where they're
thrown in like sardines they have no
privacy they have no uh freedom they are
sla they were basically slaves
you know they work
they work for like 20 cents an hour even
today
they're not allowed to you know meet
with their sp have sex with their spouse
and they they are treated like like uh
monsters and outcasts and and that's
what they become
you know a lot of people go to prison
and become radicalized the whole point
of prison is to re is to rehabilitate
people
so
that should be the goal not to make
people feel inhuman
people always go
um
what about like charles manson it's like
yeah dude and there's like one charles
manson two every million
like petty criminals in there
so i am a huge uh prison reformist thank
you dan go ahead
i don't really have anything else to say
i'm still reading about the
the rules in california says uh
uh
oh never mind
i thought it was saying that um
only your legal spouse but i don't think
that's oh you could can you like bring a
prostitute in
oh
well
i mean
i guess you couldn't it's just
anybody
anyone who chooses to come can be there
i'm not sure i read that you're supposed
to have been with someone i think for
six months at least
oh
interesting i could so they're not
they're they we don't like casual sex we
like we like committed relationships
only
well you know and in prison there's a
lot of violent sexual violence too so
it's probably good for everybody
to get that out but anyway if you go
back this is interesting if you show
that picture on my screen
um james charles was in ethiopia at the
same time as our kelly
yeah i didn't notice that when we
originally watched that video
yeah and he he was actually also
uh he also did a version of do you have
your passports do you have your shot so
that's interesting
[Laughter]
um we are uh at 33 minutes wow
flew on by didn't it having too much fun
come on
all right let me maybe i'll do two and
then i'll do another two and 30. sure
yeah we like that
guys i want to tell you today about
honey
y'all know what's up
me
[Music]
i'm sorry i yelled at you dude
it's okay i was interrupting you no it
was rude
no you weren't
kind of
was maybe a little bit
but i i i do this shtick where i yell
but i'm like trying to be funny but then
i just come off as being a dick so i'm
sorry thank you shannon shred it
i've got thick skin i'm a big boy
i can handle it thank you
i love you
what was that
i said i love you oh
oh my god
we all shop online guys it's honey we've
all seen that promo code field at tonsa
said check out but thanks to honey
manually searching for coupon codes is a
thing of the past
honey is a free shopping tool that
scours the internet for promo codes and
applies the best one
it finds to your car honey sports over
30 000 stores online they range from
tech
gaming
popular fashion brands and even food
delivery
imagine you're shopping at one of your
favorite sites when you check out the
honey button drops down and all you have
to do is click apply coupon wait a few
seconds as honey searches for coupons
and confined for that site
funny finds a
working coupon you'll watch the price
drop like magic i love honey me and hila
use it all the time it's so easy it
takes two clicks to install it's free
you don't even notice it
it's pretty incredible
um do we have any coupons money saving
coupons
i don't i have a fresh one but i can
pull up a relatively recent one
yeah i mean this this stuff happens all
the time it's hard to even keep track
it happens a lot when we're shopping for
clothing yeah and you don't even think
about it you get to the checkout don't
even think about it dude you really
don't you get to the checkout
and then automatically applies you save
like 50 you know when you're buying like
jeans or expensive clothing it could be
like 100 bucks
well there's a reason why honey has
founded 17 million members over two
billion dollars in savings come on
so if you don't already have honey you
could be straight up missing out on free
savings literally free stalls in a few
seconds and by getting it you're going
to be doing yourself a solid and
supporting this podcast thank you
i never recommend something i don't use
so get honey for free at joinhoney.com
h3tv that's jointhoney.comh3tv
thank you thank you
[Music]
stamps
we
i love me some stamps boy
if you got a small business you know
there's nothing more valuable than your
time so stop wasting it on trips to the
post office stamps.com makes it easy to
mail and ship right from your computer
save time and money with stamps.com send
letters and packages for less with
discounted rates from usps ups and more
since 1998 stamps.com has been an
indispensable tool for 1 million
businesses
sams.com brings the service of the us
postal service and ups shipping right to
your computer whether you're in office
sending invoices to side hustle on etsy
or a full-blown warehouse shipping
orderstamps.com will make your life
easier all you need is a computer and
standard printer no special supplies or
equipment is required within a minute
you're up and running printing official
postage for any letter any package
anywhere
you want to send
and you'll get exclusive discounts on
postage and shipping from ups usps and
ups once your mail is ready just
schedule a pickup or drop it off there's
no traffic there's no lines
come on cut the confusion
out of shipping with stamps.com's new
raid advisor tool you compare shipping
rates and timelines to easily find the
best options
guys
save time and money with stamps.com
there's no risk and you get a special
offer that includes a four-week trial
plus free postage and a digital scale no
long-term commitments or contracts are
required just go to stamps.com h3tv
for your four-week trial plus free
postage and a digital scale at
stamps.com
h3tv stamps.com never go to the post
office again thank you
all right
i like to don't feel too heavy
you want to do the other two
30
in another 30 or so yeah okay cool
by the way i want to thank you guys too
because
the leftovers we shot
saturday night yeah baby
saturday [ __ ] night
at 11. nowhere else i'd love it to be on
a saturday night and then i left at 11.
how long how late were you guys here
i
i don't remember exactly i got home at
like one oh 20 or something thank you
guys man i really appreciate it i felt
bad hassan's got the craziest schedule
ever so like trying to get this guy down
well you should say that that won't be
normal we uh
no we're supposed to meet
we're supposed to record on thursday
mornings right but i was sick and yeah
your voice is always something something
so we're like we got to do this
thank you guys anyway very nice
happy to be here
yeah i really appreciate it hassan was
really nice and we all just meshed
really well so yeah good vibes yeah
great vibes i think so too
very excited about the show
um
speaking of the leftovers the new show
here
we've got
um
dedicated haters already right is this
what the
um y'all wasted three million dollars on
alex jones parody studio for such an
awkward podcast lol
actually i did not first of all the
insinuation that i wasted three million
dollars
that is money well spent someone says
you know it's virtual right
i'm sorry i don't know what he's talking
about
and i love his responses what do you
mean virtual they're sitting right there
[Music]
he's got a point they think that was
pricey
good thing they don't know how much you
paid for that forest
yeah this piece of land that we're
sitting in right now
yeah dude i had to pay i'm like leasing
this land from the government yeah um
national park
yeah good point ian
the permitting alone unbelievable
to park it no but it's not a green
screen i want to make that very clear
right it's a real studio no it's very
real
actually there's a lot of people that
were like i saw some really great
comments of like um
the fact that ethan spent three million
oh jesus love just fell on dan being
attacked what you doing
me
you hit me dude
it's your problem you did something what
the [ __ ]
we shot this segment on friday lovebot
kept hitting
the back of me i don't know if it was
intentional or not but that whole
segment he was bumping me from behind
you all right yeah
we just gotta get you back into the wall
well does it not stand up on its stand
it's on the stand
hmm there's something wrong we knew
there was something wrong with this
thing
wait doesn't that happen
it was on the kickstand oh yeah i turned
the kickstarter you just turned the
kickstand off and it seems to be better
dude
yeah it's it's
yeah the thing has seen better days for
sure
oh yeah for sure yeah
yeah um
there were some great comments uh i saw
trisha stands being like the fact that
ethan spent three million dollars on
this set and they're like and i know
he's getting a better deal than trisha
is just proof of misogyny
i was like what though
pretty great no comment
go ahead call man i'm over it i'm not
holding my tongue
i'm tired of it
why shouldn't i be able to let
okay i'm not gonna say no it's just
because i just
i assume that was a fan or a watcher
that made that comment and i i don't
want to uh disparage them to
our dear our dear uh our
dear viewers yes
yeah he takes that five percent
you know what
am i should i talk can i talk about
trisha one thing i wanted to say about
her you guys are all going to veto it i
yes i'm under strict orders i'm under
borders from my boss from my real boss
well i have a real boss too yeah exactly
it's that it's not fair that i'm not
allowed to talk about her why am i not
why the sudden oh i'm gagged like i
can't talk about her because it just is
i mean she hasn't been talking about you
lately has she i don't think so
no let's just move
move
on
[Applause]
[Laughter]
well if you want to know the truth i'm
paying hassan five percent more than i
was paying tricia oh [ __ ]
people are gonna take you seriously i'm
not i'm this i'm not i'm just kidding
i'm not disclosing anything serious
about
our uh deal five percent difference is
astronomical
five percent mean zero let's take a call
we got the buzzers and everything let's
see
yeah somebody yeah
there was somebody saying there was a
potentially really good one uh here's
one about a lawsuit that sounds
interesting
comedian wants to make me laugh all
right you guys
he's 17 years old is that the age or is
that the number of the caller
oh sam said the good one hung up i think
it was somebody that knew uh your
brother from what i was hearing
yeah it was a story about sean but they
hung up
we missed it let's try this let's try
this local comedian okay all right white
he's 22 not 17.
all right
wyatt you know the drill
there's buzzers on deck
all right
how you doing
uh i've never called into anything
before so i'm kind of nervous but i'm
i'm i'm ready okay i'm i want i want to
i want to laugh
i'm going to get in a good mood
all right
you want the one minute thing or how
much time you need
i i just
i could
do one i don't have a lot i can try i
could start off with the story all right
that's like my [ __ ] here's the thing
we're not we won't put a timer on her
but these guys are brutal
piranhas on with their fingers on the
buzzer so i it's not me just know that
okay but i'm gonna i'm i'm on your team
wyatt i'm team wyatt here we go
so uh
i in iowa i used to play in bands a lot
i booked this band metro station miley
cyrus's brother was in it
and i was clipping my bass strings
and i uh i'd like the same guitar to
have him so he wasn't talking to me at
all up to that point he was like inside
the building but i guess he thought that
i like had his face so he like came up
to me and he was like oh what's up i'm
trey cyrus and he saw that it was in his
face so i was like oh what's up so i
shook his hand and i didn't notice that
i clipped my fingers um i clipped my
finger
and i was bleeding and then i shook trey
cyrus's hand and i got blood all over
his hands my blood
interesting
yeah
so i uh i kind of hoped that that got to
miley somehow
because that would be really neat or or
billy ray
can you unpack that last part for me a
little bit you want your blood to get on
miley cyrus that's the the desired
outcome
there just a little bit just because it
would be like something to laugh sorry
hold on hold on somebody hold on i
pressed mine look somebody buzzed dance
look i was like controversy yeah my
shit's flipped too oh really ian hit it
wasn't when we tested it right right no
hey my [ __ ] here this is ian's button
alright i'm gonna go it comes at me i'm
gonna go trigger happy then
it's flipped i don't hear the guy our
[ __ ] is flipped our [ __ ] is flipped
right now
all right so a b a b buzzy but you're
still alive right can you unpack you you
get one brother left can you unpack what
you mean that you got you got the blood
on miley cyrus's brother
and and you liked that why
i didn't like it i didn't like it i just
was like i was you know you're in that
situation and it already happened so
then it was like well
if it's already happened like i kind of
hope
that miley at least is like shakes his
hand or something afterwards
okay so you're saying if you're a little
bit of your blood would get on miley
cyrus that would that would please you
that would be a positive outcome for you
no no no no no it wouldn't please me it
would just it would just make me smile
it'd make me laugh it'd be a good bit
just so you know it seems like it's
pleasing you when you laugh and smile
wait wait so so you're your bases your
bass player and you were trimming your
bass strings or were you changing them
i was changing them
zach's like you're you're wiping blood
on people but yeah hold on
well because i've been in the scenario
and i know what it's like
you're the bass player zack
no but i i'm a guitarist and i i know
what it's like are you you're
questioning if he could get blood if he
could cut himself like that kinda yeah
so why i was using tin snips i was using
tin snips and my finger got in the way
because i'm i'm uh
i'm dumb
what gauge strings do you use jesus jack
can i put your hand combs over here type
what's that punk band dude i don't even
i don't even know what brand of strings
it was it's just cheap streams
okay i mean
pretty gnarly i i don't yeah i don't
so
later on that night the kid offered me
ten dollars for scooter tricks
i was hanging out outside the venue and
a kid pulled up on a scooter and he was
like i'll give you uh
if you give me ten dollars i'll do
scooter tricks for you
did you i'm not gonna do that
no no i said no
okay very interesting wow
he was like 12 13 tops and he like
pulled out this bag of weed and he's
like well if you don't have like any any
money to give me just scooter tricks
could you give me something to roll up
with
and i was like this kid's way too young
so i was like no do you bleed on him
yeah
what's that at what point do you bleed
on this small child
i i didn't believe on the child i had it
i had it
taped up by then what blood type
he turned to me and then he said because
i said you you look pretty young you
probably shouldn't be doing that and he
looked at me and he said you know what i
think and then i was like what and he
said i think you're a [ __ ] and he
scooted away in a scooter really fast
did that comment maybe a weird night
yeah that all happened in one night huh
did did billy uh did uh the dude notice
you bleed it on him or no
i saw him look at his hand but i i had
walked away are you oh negative why as
soon as he went into his into his rv
that uh metro station had and washed his
hands
interesting
your life is as an adventure my friend
yeah seriously
it's
all right we got two beepies thanks for
sharing we wish you all the best and uh
i'm hoping i'm hoping that
i am hoping that he didn't wash his
hands and that blood was somehow
transferred to miley cyrus i really hope
that blood got all over her so that uh
you're fantastic you can be fulfilled my
friend yep
dan cut him off he's out
oh you you did
that's actually good because i have a
trouble i have a hard time dropping
people
so apparently everyone does
well i was kind of i was enjoying the
ride yeah to be perfect it wasn't that
bad
well i mean zach was giggling his ass
off it was an interesting ride yeah i
mean the
wasn't necessarily funny but just the um
the ups and downs of this saw ethan at
denny's apparently ethan farted very
loud that's [ __ ] i'm gonna take this
call
there's no [ __ ] way this guy's
telling the truth
then jonah
jonah you're a [ __ ] liar
okay this is eight months ago
or something like that uh
my girlfriend works at the denny's uh
off ramirez
you saw me prime pandemic eating at
denny's
and farting super loud
i don't know how many other uh amazing
hairline
uh jews driving uh bentleys or
bentley
uh no but i i i was in there i heard you
uh i was you know obviously never didn't
come over probably get that a lot
uh but yeah no i you ripped ass like big
time what is that wearing hold on hold
on hold on okay you need to prove to me
the wearing is not the best yeah
you were wearing sandals and shorts
handles
and teddy friends
okay who was i with let's start there
who was i with
you were alone dude
yeah [ __ ] i will never i have never
been to denny's alone in my [ __ ] life
dude are you sneaking to denny's beside
yeah
the fact that you didn't say ila proves
that you're 100 wrong i would i've never
been to denny's alone in my life i'm
getting a little midnight he has an
interesting theory of like a late night
4 a.m sneak out of the house
okay so i was by myself ripping apps at
denny's bro
this is slander everyone is alone
everybody has done that at least
a lot yeah well not me buddy bye
dropped
slander
yeah he might be honest i would need a
picture to believe that to be honest
i'm at denny's by myself ripping ass
loud
i mean i'm a degenerate but give me give
me some credit it's just going crazy
without ela just eating whatever you
want
you guys better you all better [ __ ]
back off
when was the last time you were at a
denny's
years years really years dude they've
really upped their menu
i mean denny's is the last resort i
don't i'm not gonna sit here and hate on
denny's but i'm saying of all the places
that like if you're on the road if
you're traveling denny's is acceptable
but if you're in [ __ ] a neighborhood
that you know i mean who's going to
denny's
it's just you are
by myself
ripping ass
i've heard crazy
[ __ ] your pants in a booth by
yourself at 4am laughing slamming eggs
dude i haven't eaten first of all i
haven't eaten anywhere by myself out in
probably 10 years okay
yeah that was he dropped the ball there
because yeah that was an easy it wasn't
easy if he said ela then the
conversation okay
you guys think find this interesting
kd 22 says nepotism going on at work
girl sleeping with someone who also
works at the hospital
while on the clock still being promoted
in boss nose
i mean
what can i do about that yeah i don't
know
what do you want me to do
a fitness brand called h3 tv
came up and she was looking for the
phone number what
wait
fitness brand there's a fitness brand
called h3tv
tv fitness holy [ __ ]
what
did you find it i typed h3 tv fitness
and something came up came up when she
was looking bye don hillman oh she
accidentally called him oh great
oh oh okay this is a big one
anonymous 27 was at a trailer fight with
donald trump and saw ryan cavanaugh in
the flesh provided evidence oh
all right let's bring him on
so what kind of evidence did you provide
that uh
i i here i'll talk to the screeners but
we don't have your name it was a
sneaky little cheeky photo that i
snapped okay so so the screeners
have seen it and they they've confirmed
that you were there
yeah
but you must be someone of note to be
that close to the cav cave and trump or
or were you close to them or far away
i mean
it was very strange and i wasn't
necessarily i mean i was supposed to be
there but i was
i think like
in a sense was hired by
trailer and i just think i'm probably i
feel like obligated to collin because i
feel like i'm the only
wait why are you buzzing okay
that was for you that was for your
lawyer av is buzzing you for my lawyer
why i didn't i don't have no this guy
can say whatever you want yeah what the
[ __ ]
i want to hear this yeah um
appreciate it baby um sorry dude
yeah
it was uh no it's cool
uh so hold on you said you were hired by
you said you were hired by triller
not directly but yes it sounds like you
can speak event staff
right
oh that means we'll go we'll go with
that sure yeah yeah i got you say that
um okay
yeah it's
without saying too much i feel just like
i'm the only foot soldier that has like
infiltrated the trailer walls so i
thought i needed to okay so i'll just
let you know you have i oh my gosh
the master of whispers thank you bro
i mean you you sent it you sent a pic to
the screeners right let me see the
picture there you see it yeah i said oh
my goodness i'm not going to show it
right
can i show it i mean is that a public
event
he said please don't
show it this is this does appear to be a
very candid photo of ryan cavanaugh so
you snuck that huh
sure
did you feel shady taking that photo
i did it was a little
it's such good quality because it was a
snipe
if you can't tell yeah definitely
and so did you see anything interesting
that you want to report to us today
i just want yeah basically
it was so bizarre being there and like
you on tv they make it look like it's
like this full huge event right um but
essentially
and like even with like trump there you
would think it was like this grand shirt
like
like crazy thing and it just like
there were like so many empty seats
very very sad in person
and i yeah i can't describe how
different it is being there definitely
and it was like kind of sad
yeah well apparently the reports are is
that that fight lost a ton of money it's
just a financial bomb shot
which i mean i have no heart i don't
have a hard time believing that at all
yeah but yeah anything else did you
what was it like seeing this legendary
uh
it was almost like seeing like a war
criminal or something like oh [ __ ] i've
seen that guy in the history books
a little bit like
i thought he had gotten in trouble like
years ago for some like me too stuff but
i think that was him or was that we got
to correct the record here he falsified
documents i think he's
perhaps there there's a person who has a
resemblance are you thinking of harvey
weinstein yeah i think he's getting a
little confused yeah who i sent a big
[ __ ] dude no that's okay so
i have to correct the record here for
our lawyers harvey weinstein
uh is a different person than ryan
kavanagh although they look very similar
in your opinion do you see it
obviously in my opinion yeah yeah
can you make a factual statement like
what's my opinion i will say though that
it's almost like he was taking all of
the uh like a good the juicy stuff from
the back you can tell taking it to the
front for like extra right you can tell
on that youtube channel he kept doing
like this right like yeah oh it's so
his hair's flipped all right thank you
man it's nice to know we've got eyes and
ears uh in the water circles so keep
keep keep keep your ears open keep your
eyes forward and uh
make sure to call back in with any
updates
okay i sure will thank you all right
take care buddy thanks thank you thank
you for doing that good work for us
we got foot soldiers everywhere he's
right
ryan cavanaugh yeah [ __ ]
oh my god the good calls keep coming
matt keemstar at a mall over the weekend
of buffalo
all right do we have proof on that one
do we have proof on that one guys let me
let me bring him on
derek derek derek did you provide proof
that you know all right let's talk let's
talk
so um i did send the picture to a b on
instagram uh as proof okay hold on let's
just let's let's make sure we're
abey's gonna check that right now while
he's doing that why don't you tell me
was it a candid encounter or was it like
a fan meet-up
um yeah so me and my friends were at the
mall in buffalo and uh we were about to
leave and we saw a keemstar
leaving with um
a very young looking female
[Laughter]
[Applause]
and you're 18. so
you're 18 right so when you say very
young are you saying relative to your
age or just relative to human yes
uh definitely someone that i like could
have gone to high school with like for
sure mm-hmm
so um yeah uh so i managed to snap a
picture of both my friends with keemstar
uh like i said i sent it at 2ab but i
just want to clarify since i know a b
says it checks out can i show the photo
or no word yeah sure going
yeah i'll show it i'm busted
how tall are you guys by the way i want
to get a read on his height
yeah so i was just going to talk about
that so these are both my friends uh the
guy on the right uh is about six feet
tall and you can see he's lunch he's
kind of slouching over here so uh
my best estimate is that keemstar is
right about five foot eight to five foot
nine at that okay that makes sense
that's kind of what we think yeah
when we were not memeing on him he's but
i'll say based on this his stance is
alpha as [ __ ] bro oh he is straight
you guys are
are baiting over them
the guy in the blue shirt i would say is
fairly no but if you chart his his if
you chart his trajectory that's
definitely it's a little bit of a slant
i guess you're right i guess you got to
be you got to be that knight you got to
be that perfect straight up if you want
to be alpha
but uh yeah so like keepstar apparently
frequents the small like quite often and
i'm not the first one of my friends who
have seen him there so i mean if y'all
want to see keemstar i mean
you know where to go let's yeah let's
not say them all oh yeah please don't
please but what i do find interesting is
you know who likes malls more than most
[Laughter]
[Music]
young girls yeah maybe high school age
girls love them all did you see what
store any stores you was walking into or
children's places
was taken uh this photo's taken right
outside um the urban outfitters so
perfect
yeah
um did he
did the girl he with have any bags or
anything was she did she do any shopping
ah
i don't recall all i remember is just an
ex i'm pretty sure it was that it was
that a quote assistant he has
right right right
that uh this kind of like runs around
with something like that but
yeah it was it was pretty crazy man
that's awesome well you saw you saw
god between ryan kavanaugh siding and
keemstar sighting it's like the whole
axis of evil we're getting we're getting
some real gold today
thanks bro for sharing that all right
yeah thanks a lot for calling for sure
all right
i just wanted to clear the name of
buffalo of buffalo fans you got a lot of
poopa troopers out here hell yeah and
you know it's not just keemstar out here
man so i just want to say we love you
we love buffalo you know what derek
i accept that wholeheartedly i may have
said bad things about buffalo and attack
but i take it back we love buffalo i
love you guys please uh
take
please accept my uh my apologies for any
buffalo slam okay you did all right
thank you thank you bro thank you
appreciate you love you peace and love
thank you bro
oh you think keems right into this
dear susan
today somebody oh this is what trisha
would say i have a new soccer
[Music]
a man named derrick stalked me
and sent it to ethan
and ethan is promoting
and now that he's coming
i didn't want to go down this road yeah
hey didn't we have like a new one with
the brother banks in the background oh
for real we did that yeah did you do
that jesus what's happening with lovebot
today
he's trying to like man i don't know
you're [ __ ] attacking me
oh love's not even on cam do
oh it hasn't rendered
all right we'll get we'll get that for
next time dude lovebot is [ __ ]
wilding out that shit's flipped dude
you better get his shots and passports
yeah i better
gotta get your ass out here
i'm supposed to have fika with him later
how am i supposed to do it
by the way
i see all these comments with people
like
the love just gets overlooked and pete
always talk and it's just it's so upset
i was like [ __ ] i sp i bought a
four thousand dollar robot so you could
be in the room with us what more do you
want from me
it's hard
and it's hard to communicate for me
because i'm on like a two second delay
right and it's
weird yeah and that goes for us
for everyone too everyone's allowed to
sit in and participate however they want
just so everyone knows because i've seen
a few comments saying that we leave sam
out or you know everyone's welcome to
so i join
this doesn't make you sound like a dude
it doesn't that was a nice comment yeah
i don't know why that would make you
feel like
zach is so funny zach is so brutal on
you maybe
i love i love baby just for the record i
got some criticism for you zach what
love is a human being you don't need to
say fika every time you talk to him
he doesn't mind he loves
no i like it i'm popularizing it
it's like if you said lebanon every time
you talk to me oh i do
right
dude bro
fire lebanon
food today oh really i'm hungry yeah
what's it called
it's a milk salad i know that's yeah
cheese pies dude so good you put lemons
let me hit that is that like isn't that
also sour cheese
no no it's like a pita with like a oh
the sausage the green spice
yeah yeah yeah and there's like a bunch
of sesame seeds and stuff
and then we put some of the lemna on
there and holy [ __ ] yo so um
i don't know which photo to believe but
he also submitted this one
oh this is the pre-photoshopped one i
think yeah oh sweet thank you
oh this looks good so what's the story
here where'd you get this
so uh me and lena found a bakery near
our house after living here for a year
and craving it
yeah that's like a
pizza yeah it'll look better out of the
bag it's too much glare that's caked in
it boy yep yeah it's this spice called
zatar i don't know what it's actually
made out of i looked it up it's like
cumin and uh thyme and thyme and a bunch
of it's just like a mix of a bunch of
herbs and stuff yum
sesame seeds and then yeah he suggested
put the lemno cheese on there
a little
dip on the side holy [ __ ]
you know what you're doing bro yep
there's a good chat all right i'm okay
then
take this away from me please i'm
begging you it kind of tastes like pizza
mm-hmm yeah it's really good mm-hmm
um
whole fam is mormon wants to talk about
craziness i mean
i believe you
you know
so this person says they're in a lawsuit
and they want to know wait real quick
real quick so
i don't know there's like kind of a new
thing on youtube where it's showing now
members
um how many months they've been a member
which is cool
but they're able to like send a message
when it does that renewal so it's kind
of like a super chat but they're not
actually donating anyways somebody named
josephine just said donna used to do my
grandma's hair in mexico and she used to
talk crap about her kids how do i call
in about this
oh
i'll listen to her but there's no way my
mom was talking [ __ ] about her kids like
i'm not even gonna entertain that yeah
okay baby now oh listen i'll listen
i mean the number 808 hot meme yeah call
into the hot memes you know that's
that's the best way to call in i mean so
the detail that's in did my mom ever say
that she cut hair in mexico
not that i recall because she did do
that so that detail does add some
credibility to the claim
[ __ ] baby [ __ ] my mom [ __ ] baby salon
because there's a bunch of expatriates
there
my mom
you got you got to remove this yeah
yeah get it i can't help myself
thank you baby it's very good
shredder chill um
my mom's such entrepreneur she said she
built her own salon there
and because she's this experienced
hairdresser
there was a big demand there for it
what's funny
the chewing is the chewing sorry it's a
lot yeah i'm sorry it's a lot
so it is interesting that they know that
detail
so i'll entertain the call but there's
no way my mom would talk [ __ ] about the
kids that i don't believe
i could have guessed that your mom cut
hair in mexico i mean she said she's
been doing it i forget how long she
mentioned it before but also i knew they
lived in mexico for a while so
i could have put two and two together
it doesn't seem like i mean this is a
long-term fupa trooper they've been a
member for a long time i mean why makes
i mean i'm not saying it's [ __ ] i'm
just saying somebody would go on the
internet and just lie
no if they call in i'll talk to them all
right i'm going to defend my mom on this
screeners
look out for josephine
[Music]
oh wow now
i think by me calling that out
everybody's discovered that that's a
feature now because we're getting like a
million
members now well thank you to the
members you all send a message yeah i
think that actually is a really cool
feature you all deserve it yeah
damn some of these people
did that say 14 months someone says they
saw ryan cavanaugh fall down stairs but
then it disappeared i guess it wasn't a
real thing
here's one that says
what do you guys think about this
my fiance and me
are in a lawsuit and i want ethan's
opinion about who's in the wrong
this
judge ethan
nice
uh there is a bit to unpack there
they're they're currently engaged but
they're suing each other no no no no no
wait
is that what it means i mean
maybe i'm misunderstood hold on michael
are you suing your fiance
no i'm not saying that's okay
uh no we're in this lawsuit together
all right what's the deal give me give
me the reader's digest on this lawsuit
background
okay
yeah i'll break it judge ethan is about
to rule on this the shortest way
possible
so and are you the plaintiff or the
defendant
i'm the defendant
okay i like defendants i'm always
defendant yeah
i'm biased towards the defendant right
oh no sorry sorry i'm the plaintiff
that wasn't a real
we can discount that that x that one all
right
all right
all right michael lay it out for us
okay so basically this is over real
estate uh my fiance and i just purchased
a house um this was we closed in may we
were supposed to move in in june
and um and and
side note we are paying our mortgage
right now and um
but so basically
yeah we bought this house and we were
about to start building some stuff we
were going to build a
culvert pipe
and we were going to get a permit
through the city and then the city
basically told us that we can't get any
permits to build anything because our
house is on an illegal track
and so what that means is basically
um
our the sellers uh were
given this property to
their grandparents which are the
neighbors now the grandparents owned a
bunch of acreage around the area
um
and they subdivided their land to give
their grandkids who we bought from this
house and they did that in 2015.
now
they didn't subdivide
correctly they didn't do it through the
city and so the city is saying hey this
property is void because um they didn't
do it so is the city telling you
that you can't even own like do they
want to condemn your house
dude we can't
we can't do anything with it we can't
even sell it okay let me know like
there's a point in every sale where they
have there's mandatory disclosures the
seller
as is yeah yeah
well
can you do as is i think they need to
disclose
if it's properly
uh
permitted yeah
right right and so okay so here's the
thing
hold on hold on the scales of justice
have come out for this one and i've got
a hammer wait you just go up real quick
so i'm here i'm ready to make a verdict
and it is binding so okay street court
go ahead well and i was going to give
you i was going to give you a few
options on who you think this is fault
you know is it is it the sellers is it
the realtors and mind you
their realtor and our realtor work for
the same broker
is it the
is it the lender's fault is it the title
company's fault or is it us my fiance
and i first-time homebuyers
it's not your fault
i would say it's not the lender's fault
either i mean the i mean the lender has
some it's not the lender's fault they
send out people to
to appraise properties to to protect
their investment but it's not their
fault
it's not your fault
what is that that's uh
also
just an update that we got uh this
following or this past week from our
attorneys is um
they found some open record documents on
uh the grandparents so like i said the
grandparents subdivided and gave the
land to their grandkids who we bought it
from the grandparents um signed papers
uh with the county clerk's office saying
that
acknowledging that if you sell this
property to someone outside of your
family it becomes uh void and like i
said it it's an illegal track so
it sounds to me like
it sounds to me like you need to get
your money back
that's what that's our first option so
we sent a demand letter to all the
parties involved and we said you know
our what we want to do is just back out
this entire thing we get our money back
and we're back on the market looking for
a new home
and uh so everybody
had replies of saying you know this
isn't our fault we'll fight you
vigorously and in litigation and
um you know so everyone's obviously not
gonna claim that this is their fault and
so that's why
uh oh thank you we're filing suit
actually we're filing suit this week
actually um and we're suing everybody in
this wig um
i got a new wig
nice so yeah all right here's my here
first of all i'm sorry this is a very
unfortunate situation being a first time
home buyer is stressful and you you just
don't know it's a complicated process
you don't really understand it right up
your first time right out the gate it's
hard
what i'm what i'm confused about is like
how was this not
uncovered through disclosures through
um
like exactly like your age i mean your
agent or
was the house
was it appraised
was it ever um was it did you have a
home inspection was there ever anything
of this sort
obviously obviously we got the house
inspected and uh there was an appraiser
um but they're
they're all of them aren't liable for
any of this you know they just come here
they do their job and they get the
report and the appraiser they don't know
that this isn't on a on a legal track
the obviously the only people that knew
about this was the grandparents so i
don't even think the sellers necessarily
knew this the grandkids who we bought
the house from i think their
grandparents are obviously the ones that
screwed them but unfortunately we didn't
buy this house from the grandparents so
we can't sue the grandparents we're
suing no yeah you you uh i think it's
their i think it's their fault and for
it's not like it's their fault but
unfortunately you know i think you're in
the right i think they need to give the
money back and uh
it's not they can't legally sell it so
you know that's kind of the bottom line
right
right
that's it return the money return the
money
get back
appreciate it all right take care good
luck with that that sounds like a
[ __ ] nightmare bro i hope you get
that resolved yeah thank you
i'm sorry bro i'm really sorry you're
dealing with that it's not your fault
thanks michael
it's not your fault
nice wig
yes um well
there
might be some things being cooked up in
the near future
maybe some upgrades
shout out to olivia finding that way
man that that is just horrid i mean
horrid situation yeah
i mean look as the seller i feel like
you gotta be you gotta just
bite the bullet and be like yo
you're like you know i mean i can't sell
this house legally right hopefully it's
a quick and
i don't know
tough one
all right let's move on what we got in
the dock
oh
uh you know what we have two more ads we
got to do i think it's time
and then we can get back to the dock all
right we've made it
we've made it like three or four yeah
like three links into the dock so far we
have a lot of stuff so
yeah let's get to all that
plenty to talk about here today folks
but before all that hello fresh
with hellofresh you get that fresh
pre-measured ingredients and
mouth-watering seasonal recipes
delivered right to your door
skip the trips to the grocery store and
count on hellofresh to make cooking easy
fun and affordable and that's why it's
america's number one meal kit this is
the infamous
chowder
what kind of chowder was it uh it's like
a corn pepper chowder
dreamy good soup
it's so good soup good soup
was the bread included as well yeah was
that kind of like a garlic bread what is
that yeah kind of a garlicky thing i'm
on day three i brought it with me so you
still hitting that yeah
wow that's passion
that's quality
that's hello fresh
the fall harvest is officially on with
hellofresh count on seasonal recipes
like pumpkin cinnamon rolls and
friends giving ready sides as well as
fresh high quality ingredients to travel
from the farm to your front door in less
than a week you're going to get better
value with hellofresh you're gonna get
30 percent cheaper than shopping at a
grocery store with pre-portioned
ingredients that ensure you won't spend
money on excess food that ends up going
in the trash
that's the hellofresh experience
yeah i mean they send you pre-portioned
beautiful
ingredients fresh as can be the box has
got like the uh
ice packs in it
so it comes nice and fresh and cool
and man it's just a great experience you
don't have to worry about shopping
measuring the
they make it as simple as possible to
have a beautiful wholesome home-cooked
meal it's great
go to hellofresh.com h3tv14
and use code h314 for up to 14 free
meals
feeding america out here including free
shipping
that's hellofresh.com
h3tv14 and use code h314 for 14 free
meals what the flip
you know what
it's hello fresh america's number one
meal kit thank you thank you
peace and love peace and love
and finally it's policy genius
[Music]
summer
uh listen to properly provide
for your families people need more than
10 times life insurance coverage than
they get through their employer you guys
don't get any life insurance people give
life insurance
you guys want life insurance
from an employer that's what it says
i've never heard of that but me neither
hook it up i was like [ __ ] i like the i
love okay
you know if someone relies on your
financial support whether it's a child
an aging parent or even a business
partner
life insurance is always a great idea
policy genius makes it easy to compare
quotes from over
i had life insurance at the lottery
that's what cam said oh damn do you
still have it cam how does that work
he says he doesn't think so so they're
like well if you're with us good luck
you can die in peace
once you leave
you could die in agony
i'd personally rather get paid well than
have life insurance it's like we'll pay
you when you die
it's like no pay me when i'm alive
hmm i see that's i thought that sounded
both man you could do both but i get
what you're saying my wife could figure
it out we're going to add dental and uh
i by the way soon really and the next up
next update
this guy hell yeah brother
anyway
policy genius makes it easy to compare
quotes from over a dozen top insurers
all in one place why should you compare
well let me tell you you could be saving
50 or more on life insurance by
comparing quotes with policy genius you
could be saving 1300 or more per year on
life insurance
by using policy genius to compare
policies there's a ton of people in the
chat saying that they get life insurance
from their i didn't know that was the
thing like
me neither but like
lots of comments saying yeah i get life
insurance for my work life insurance a
good thing man
and actually from what i've life
insurance is like really um
cost effective it's super cost effective
and like people rarely get [ __ ] over
because it's like heavily regulated
right like you know insurers are always
like i'm not gonna pay like life
insurance is really like you get paid
unless you like killed your wife or
burned your you know whatever you're not
talking about that during that rate well
don't obviously don't kill your wife
they might not appreciate it
don't i mean don't do it
murder is bad is that a surprise to
anyone
[Music]
you know
anyway
as i was saying
the license expert at politics unions
work for you not the insurance company
so you can trust them to help you
navigate every step of the shopping and
buying process hit the tom selleck sound
deck
it's the i probably can't trust me okay
it's all the same as the music so you
can the kind of service that has earned
policy genius thousands of five-star
reviews across trustpilot and google and
eligible applicants can get covered in
as little as a week thanks to an
award-winning policy
option that swaps the standard medical
exam requirement for a simple phone call
that is great
when me and ela got life insurance it
was like they had to come and they could
do all these tests on you to put you in
a laboratory
this exclusive policy was recently rated
number one by forbes advisor higher than
options from ladder ethos and best out
whoever the [ __ ] those losers are
bestow every time bestow these nuts in
your mouth [ __ ]
[Applause]
is what i think about their company
getting started is so easy just head to
policygenius.com
h3tv and minutes you can work out how
much life insurance coverage you need
and compare personalized quotes to find
your best price when you're ready to
apply the policy genius team will handle
the paperwork and scheduling for free
policy genius doesn't add an extra cost
head to policygenius.com h3tv to get
started right now that's policy genius
when it comes to insurance it's nice to
get it right yes we love you
policy genius
hey
all right
now hit me with a you could trust me
you guys want to know how to look more
masculine
definitely i trust them yeah i think you
can too thank you tom that's how i feel
about policy jesus this is so um
this is another this is alpha male
official alpha m official oh this is the
official account for
alpha males yeah oh sick i didn't know
that they had he he is the the alpha of
these dudes wait i've seen this guy who
is this guy you've probably seen him on
shark tank yeah he has a big youtube
channel he was on shark tank yeah he's
on charlotte what uh
alpha product it says aaron marino is
that him for like the account name
no his account name is alpha or right
under it it says aaron marino
well oh yeah
well well regardless
oh i know why he's familiar uh
he like made a video about us we talked
about him once wait he made a video
about me yeah about what did he say
about me
huh let me look
that i'm a beta
aaron marino here i am stink by the way
this is a photoshop guys so don't be
confused feminism is a way of saying now
is it comfortable this is what this
caller thinks i'm doing on my weekends
by myself i'm going to denny's and just
[ __ ] stinking up the whole place solo
yeah
he sent this as ethan's
this was his verification come on down
to ethan's it smells like ass
thanks
wait this guy's talked about me huh
i think it was about your hair actually
oh he had recommendations h3 podcast
ethan responds to alpha m
hmm
this guy has your hairline to be honest
this seems to be some commentary channel
talking about it oh
a popular youtuber whose hairline sucks
oh you [ __ ]
you're right
you see you peter
pull up that video this dude made a
video saying my hairline sucks first of
all who asked you [ __ ] and second of
all who the [ __ ] are you
i'mma teach you about being what alpha
means
pull that [ __ ] up [ __ ] yeah i think i
found it you want to talk about alpha
i'm about to show you who's alpha
i'm more of a sigma man myself
all right let's watch this video
listen to this guy talk about being
alpha
this is a feminine way of sitting now is
it comfortable sure do i sit like this
again
but if you get a beta he just admit to
sitting like that
[Applause]
is it comfortable ah he just
self-reported veda
[Laughter]
i would never sit like that i only ever
sit like this bro because i assert
dominance and i control the space
and that's real alpha [ __ ] i wouldn't
even confess to sitting across like you
blitzy ass beta
go ahead play that what is this guy said
about me
oh uh
oh i think
am i muted oh yeah i always mute youtube
so it doesn't interrupt the show
so much better is mr ethan klein ethan
has incredibly thick coarse curly hair
he's gone short he's gone long he's gone
fro ethan's another one of those
youtubers that i absolutely love and his
hair is definitely in need of a little
more tlc than he's currently giving it
now the incredible thing about ethan his
hair is so crazy thick it's crazy curly
one of the problems with thick coarse
curly hair is that if you don't
understand it if you don't nurture it
and love it and get a hair stylist that
understands how to cut it it can be a
disaster but it could be better like
this with the right product the right
cut ethan could have curly luscious
locks you can't be serious like this you
should go see a stylist who understands
curly hair you might need some type of
relaxer or character you've got to be
[ __ ]
my hairline sucks you got me all worked
up
well because the video is for popular
youtubers whose hairstyle sucks he talks
rules he talks about a bunch of
youtubers but he specifically cites for
that stuff wait wait wait i gotta see
him talk [ __ ] about other people's
hairlines real fast who did he call out
uh well as you could probably predict
logan
jesus kind of brutal like i'm making
jokes here but actually to be like yo
logan your hairline sucks bro well he's
the alpha male i mean this is the
here's the choice
and this actually has a lot of views yo
he's got a lot of subs i'm telling you
he's the original popular yeah he's the
alpha alphas if you will
gentlemen he's usually not that bad to
be honest from what i've seen of him
veda
let's see anything good here
balls ears stop
seven hard things every guy should give
up
men hate this
oh boy
yeah this seems a little
much well let's watch this tick tock i
guess he didn't say anything mean about
me but uh
that's all right but this video is
pretty pretty interesting so
here you go
take note beta males
to be perceived as more masculine you
need to actually spread a little bit man
spread right the whole idea is this this
is so horrible to put out there we do
not i do not need women thinking that
i'm consciously going into public places
and man spreading like that's the last
thing we need we don't need any more
gender warfare dude
like i have to de-escalate look i have
the size
[ __ ] between my legs it's just my
natural inclination is that my thighs
are going to spread a little bit i don't
need people like him going out in the
subways and just spreading out like this
is not helping the male cause
this is not good
his first pose is exactly how i sit that
is my natural comfort the beta pose hit
him with it hit him with that sound bite
what was it crossing your legs yeah you
know michael corleone man this michael
corleone says oh [ __ ]
but no that's not what he that wasn't
what he was doing yeah sitting like this
sitting like this is
is he was doing it with like like closed
calls yeah he was doing like one of
these yeah dainty little the open cross
i think is cool it's alpha like this
that's beta i can't sit like that dude
yeah my thighs have gotten too fat for
me to sit like that
this is a feminine way of sitting now is
it comfortable sure do i sit like this
occasionally yes but if you want to be
personal dude this guy is so deeply
disturbed he's like i like sitting like
this it's comfortable for me but it's
just to
beta i can't be myself yeah that's rough
anytime anyone's advice is don't be
yourself don't [ __ ] like what's his
name
his whole thing was like stop being
yourself yeah stop never ever do it
never ever ever be yourself
you are pathetic you are a beta never
ever ever ever be yourself be a beta
oh
beta ethan what happened
side note
jose donated ten dollars i was the
waiter at denny's where ethan was eating
that dad
confirmed that ethan did in fact rip ass
i've been hung up on twice in order to
suppress this info i must speak we are
not jose you're being called out
put them on multiple parties let's put
it on the line we'll get another guy
who's like
you were there
with a with a
a whole group of friends i was like yeah
we're right i don't do anything with
anybody ever
no way jose
all
that's more right
you need to actually spread a little bit
man spread right the whole idea is to
take up space
when we actually sit and we are
occupying more space this is seen as a
more dominant position also more
dominant body language but if you're
somebody that is
sitting very small this is something
that typically women will do more than
men can i ask a serious question i'm
sorry if there's going to ruffle some
feathers but all of these pickup artists
who pre talk about how to be masculine
are very
likely closeted gay men
[Music]
i don't think so this is
this man and the other guy owen are like
so they are they're like have these they
just seem so
i don't know bro i get gaydar
my gaydar is humming
i'm sorry maybe in some i don't get it
from this guy and that isn't really for
me either i think they're just insecure
oh
this is a feminine way of sitting now
it's a council okay
well that is that is what we're trying
to figure out
let's see what other hot ticks he has
it's okay to be single yeah there's
nothing wrong with you not wanting to be
in a relationship if you want to go play
the field with tons of spicy sandy reeds
do it if you're just like yo i'm going
to invest in me okay well he thinks he's
gay
uh the thing from the sound
yeah they're all right okay you are a
transgender
oh i wouldn't say he's transgender we
don't have any evidence of that
so
not sure where that came from
you know
there's a decent amount of agreeing with
you on
the chat but then there's also people
saying that it's a really cringe take
it's a split i i what's cringe about is
that i'm saying that like i just think
that that you know not everybody who's
homophobic or you know is you know
overly masculine is secretly gay it's no
you know
are like have crazy [ __ ] like
feminine energy
see i don't really feel that from this
guy maybe a little bit with owen maybe a
little bit with owen but not this guy's
like bro
oh my god oman is would love to be a
bottom
never be a beta i'm sorry to say that
but i just get the vibe that he loved
nothing better didn't get real
all right
this guy too i get i'm sorry and not all
gay people are feminine thank i guys i'm
like stuck in a [ __ ]
i'm stuck in a [ __ ] black hole of
kids
not all gay people are feminine
not all pickup artists are closeted gay
you don't have to make the disclaimer
right i'm not i'm not using it i'm not
trying
i'm stuck [ __ ] play that again please
you left me in a black hole of raging
confusion that's where i am right now
man
it's okay for you to have that opinion
and like i said there was a lot of
people agreeing with it but i i i just
disagree look
you guys know i'm an ally
uh a lot of people demanding a poll do
you want a poll
sure i mean make it worse what is the
yeah gay or straight is this guy a
closeted gate because that that seems
inappropriate let's not let's not yeah
sorry i see you we see you asking for
the poll we're not going to do them
i'm going to be mad at us yes or no i'm
going to rise above yes we're going to
do a poll if
but you guys know you guys know i'm an
ally that actually is funny i'm going to
do that
okay that's good let's start with the
pull up
roll i am an ally of our lgbtq
friends and uh i support them forever
always
but at the same time
no no no exception
no but
all right i just started the poll let's
see what happens oh we got the okay we
got the lady who says
my mom was talking [ __ ]
about
about oh yeah yeah we got her
interesting all right let's let's take
this call wait right before you do
josephine don't hang up we're going to
get to you yeah just real quick
dan just donated ten dollars and said he
was the manager at the denny's he had to
have one of his stir stand there and
breathe in the smell just to make it go
away faster it's incredible how many
people what
it was like the the grassy knoll uh the
gras uh the hairy it was like dallas and
and
yeah everybody was there at that denny's
on that fateful day okay
i rolled in on bentley to denny's just
to rip ass by myself i don't own a
bentley by the way
okay sorry to interrupt let's let's find
out about your mom in mexico
all right this is interesting
all right so first of all
josephine hi how are you
hi i'm good how about you okay so let's
get some facts straight first and
establish your credibility
okay yeah what's the name of the town my
mom lived in
ajijic okay so
this is the real deal oh
interesting
well
she did say ahi on a family's episode
i'll go ahead and tell you that because
my grandma has had a second home in
augie geek my entire life
um okay okay let me let me quiz you let
me quiz you on some ajijic because i've
spent a lot of time there okay why is it
called ajijic
[Music]
you know what what what geographical
feature
oh there's the mountain in the lake
and there's lake chapala
and it's pertains to the lake and the
mountain next to it yes
i think she's legit yeah she's legit
okay this is the real deal here and then
i also
i have a screenshot pertaining to this
that i just dm'd
zach and ab on instagram so i'm telling
you this is all legit okay i have no
reason to let me see the screenshots i
believe you are a lie i first of all i
believe
so your grandma used to go to my mom to
get
actually hold on before we get too deep
into this there's actually
in the forest behind us not only is
there the ground rising but i have a
alpha male 1 uh if you guys are
wondering how i get my so much alpha
energy i have my personal consultant
who's always uh just over your shoulder
yeah it's a it's very habit habits added
habit king kong ain't got [ __ ] on me
okay thank you
okay so your grandma went to my mom
for her hair needs
yes so my grandpa lives in america but
is just another white lady her and her
husband have
gotten a second home in iv and there was
a group of white ladies that were all
friends as you said like the ex-patriots
they all
lived there and hung out
i'm reading the text let me see do you
happen to know of an american couple
that used to live in a heat six years
in 2010 named donna gary
from california she was a hairdresser
very beautiful and very cool
she had my hair for years
i didn't even offer up that she was a
hairdresser and my grandma was like i
know this lady i'm 100
i'm 100 believing the details at this
moment do you keep it touch it all her
son is very famous oh thank you for
saying that about me
you're gonna this second this next text
man you can read it if you want okay
no one day they were just gone back to
california yeah off the record uh-oh let
me read this silently
yeah so my grandma told me this part is
off the record i've been hanging on to
this since august you could see the date
in the text that's horrible and i was
like
i know i was like i need to call
even about this
right
that makes me feel horrible
what the hell
but that's just not true
no i don't think anyone should read it
or maybe it's worse if i read it the
thing is this is sec this is
i don't know why
i don't know why
i think people are going to think it's
worse than what it is
you've seen it
yeah we're looking at it right now i
i think so my grandma's probably being
over dramatic
and then
as older white ladies are in the salon
yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah
yeah okay i'm gonna read it so sh so
your nana said off the record dude your
your grandma's a gossiper this is pretty
epic though i mean you you must have a
good idea
yeah
i like your grandma just because you
guys are so open and texting and stuff
that's pretty cool that's true yeah off
the record your grandma said it was
always gossiped like everybody knew
about that they moved here to make a
break from their lazy
highly entitled always asking for money
children ha
brutal jesus
cutley
wrecked
that's horrible baby no
yeah okay i'll first of all i have to
defend my mom here i'll record it i
might know my grandma said
your grandma just got out of his [ __ ]
dude
this is like so on the record right now
okay i have to i have to defend my mom
first of all actually i have to defend
myself i was in college i never asked my
parents for money once
my brother was always very
self-sufficient i don't think he ever
asked for money
my sister she's been working
at the time she just had a baby
i they sold their business and they
retired there because it was cheap and
they wanted to go on like an adventure
and [ __ ] so
ugh that's just that that is i don't i
don't think that's the reason why
i don't recall there being lots of
mooching and begging for money
i thought it was out of character i was
like oh that is not what i was expecting
to hear at all because like when i think
of you and i guess now your siblings now
that i've seen them and like i didn't
think that lined up
um but
it was very interesting to me that she
worded it that way do we get my mom to
call in what was your grandma's name
um
you can tell me private tell you could
tell type it privately because i want to
ask my mom if she remembers this lady
i will say i have
cmd
your father on twitter about this
i think he knows who i'm talking about
um because i
put like commented this on a family's
episode and your dad replied and was
like okay i'm calling my mom right now
hold on
hold on hold on i'm calling my mom she's
i'm putting this on speaker
oh my god this is gonna be a [ __ ] story
i don't know if it's louder like this or
like this
where's my mom oh yeah that's true what
does my mom have to do she's not
answering the phone
she's probably talking [ __ ] about you
yeah
she goes oh god he wants more money
mom
hi you reached the sign
great let me call my dad
you know in your mom's defense it could
have just been barbershop talk where her
grandma was talking [ __ ] and she's like
oh yeah my my kid same thing yo her
grandma says it was rumored like
everybody knew there's no good good for
nothing kids
well and i will okay wait i think i got
my dad here dad you there
okay
you're on you're live on the show just
to warn you okay
okay thanks for the warning are you do
you have a minute sure okay so i have a
young lady here
who says her grandma used to get
haircuts from mom and she's proven that
this is the real deal here so this is
real
well mom's here also you want her to
join oh yeah i tried calling her this is
this is more pertaining to mom
okay donna come here she never has her
phone with her as your sister
will verify
now um
can you say your can you say your
grandma's name or her first name and
maybe last initial
yeah i'll say her first name
and i guessed her husband's name and
last initial okay
i'll tell so mom this this woman says
her grandma used to get her hair cut
from you in mexico
and
oh wow okay so so the name is go ahead
her name is linda f linda s do you
remember cutting someone's hair linda s
[Music]
they're from alabama
what'd your grandma look like my mom's
asking
um she was kind of a little bit of like
a bigger lady with short blonde hair
bigger lady with short blonde hair
linda you know
it sounds really familiar okay well
here's the deal
she said
they said she said
off the rack well okay i'm not off the
record we gave her that she says it was
gossiped this this is this is
she says it was gossiped
that they moved to mexico to make a
break from their lazy highly entitled
always asking for money children
what yeah especially you no i wow why
would we tell
strangers go ahead
why would she say something like that
yeah well she said it off the record
it's more it's more um
it's more josephine's fault to be honest
it's truly my fault well i've never
shared anything like that you see i told
you that my mom would never say that
there's no way even i would never say
that no there's no way
yeah now does you know someone reached
out to us either in a youtube comment or
a dm or something
telling me that mom also had cut their
mothers or their grandmother's hair i
don't know all this white
i don't know if that's the same person
but
i don't know but there's no way that i
would have ever said anything like that
because it's not true it's so not true
i used to talk so nicely about everybody
that's what i think too my mom would i
have a hard time hearing that my mom
would complain about there's no way
no way all right all right i wanted to
give you guys a chance to uh defend
yourselves thank you you want to shout
out your cameo
what what's that thing you want to shut
out your cameo
oh yeah yeah i'm on cameo you guys as a
matter of fact um i just came back from
grocery shopping and that's what i was
doing i was doing cameos
fantastic all right thank you guys
thank you so much
all right there you have it you see
josephine my parents love us
i well that's what i assumed i wasn't
out of pocket for my grandma to say that
um you tell your you tell your grandma
we played this for everybody to hear
and how dare she
i'm just probably not gonna talk to my
grandma because she's gonna be like
josie's off the record yeah yeah it's
all good but that's kind of a funny
little uh
weird cul-de-sac there
all right thank you josephine
yeah thank you
did you happen to see me in a danny's uh
passing gas or do you want to throw
anything like that in there while you're
on the call
no but i will say i have gone to a live
taping of the wendy show
oh did you drop are you a fan do they
make you go whoop whoop like
they make you do that
i am not a fan but i went to new york
with like my gay best friend and wendy
is his everything
um and it was incredibly boring i will
go ahead and say that
how dare you
die
well i wish you uh i wish you a uh
toasty beef jerky uh
a lightly roasted beef jerky stick to
you and uh all the best okay
yeah have a good one all right thank you
josephine take care
[Music]
great now now i have like
[Applause]
she just added like 20 therapy sessions
to my roster with that one i mean
it sounds like
josephine's nana is just a
[ __ ] talker it's interesting she just
threw that in there too it's like nobody
asked right
she's like oh yeah i remember them and
the one thing i need to tell you is that
they hate their kids
it's like okay nana
well your parents seem to give up did we
lose internet
is that possible my document is not
loading
no i mean we're live right now i my
mine's not working either my document oh
it's google
and my youtube but the live stream is up
i'm seeing the chat still that's going
people donations are coming up you got
internet back there
are you hardwired
i am maybe it's the wi-fi the wi-fi
having a little issue is cam hardwired
he's on
how odd yeah internet seems fine over
here
all right well
do we have any long-form reactions
because i kind of like doing those on
the show because i can't really do them
in any other um i don't know about super
long i did include so much good stuff
don't you posted a a video um last night
i don't know if you saw his latest video
it is very very you wanna watch the
donkey video why not all right i love
donkey
uh real quick though um sad femme
donated five dollars said um
don't make do not i was the only one
and uh i had to see people as far away
as possible
man
it just didn't happen
i don't know there's a lot of evidence
to the contrary
well i have no internet so i don't know
what to tell you guys
it's just straight up not working
nothing mine's yeah mine same thing this
is very complicated let me turn it off
and turn it back on yeah that helps the
old off and on again trick
we're back
how weird that that would happen to both
of us
it must have been the wi-fi then because
yeah i am hardline so we're
energetically aligned we are we are bro
i'm such thing as coincidence all right
let's check out what donkey's been up to
of the video game variety
video game donkey he's so cool
he is so so cool
what the america recast mario movie yes
okay we can watch that
first of course is mario
who will be played by chris pratt
he's so cool
he's been talking a lot with the movie
can you believe what they did out here
oh yeah i did see that they put chris
pratt as mario
in the mario movie
i can't believe what they did out here
[Music]
you know this is labriolas right
yeah i don't know how to feel about the
chris pratt one but toad i'm very
excited for i'm amazed how many people
he got to india
yeah well
they're doing a mario movie chris pratt
is mario how do you feel
i'm just a worker at mario's excuse me
what location is this prattville oh okay
so you guys must love chris pratt down
there am i right there am i right
i'm not sure you don't know who he is
no for the role of bowser we cast
funnyman jack black i can't wait to see
what joseph even asked for us this time
well hot topic so is this like a
japanese person who like mastered the
english night like how did they
translate it so bad like the language
he's so funny jack black funny man he's
so cool
the original person speaking in the
video was uh miyamoto the no but who's
doing the voiceover like that cool
perfect
weird english
i don't know you know what i mean
i feel like that was not natively
translated
cool he's so cool
jack black bunny man he's so cool
terrible news
terrible absolutely terrible news they
put dennis hopper may he rest in peace
dennis hopper is bowser can you believe
the nerve of these people uh this is a
firearm store wolf wolf bark bark jack
nicholson will play change i love that
picture i don't i have no idea who
you're talking about so
i can't give an opinion you don't know
chris pratt who well you know mario
right mario
oh the game yeah
i think it's a good pick
what chris pratt is mario it's
ridiculous yeah that's an outrage who
would you cast if you could pick anybody
who would you pick
shaquille o'neal do you think john
goodman could work oh john goodman would
be good except he's so big once again
reprising his role as berto is the actor
more so i start to get confused because
the voice actor
yeah these are fake sounds exactly like
the real one they did a really good job
and then when i first saw this birdo as
morgan freeman i was like wait a minute
my name is birdo
i've seen a lot
sometimes you get busy living or you get
busy birdoing sure he's so cool shooting
eggs out of your mouth i just shoot eggs
out my mouth all day
i pass the days just shooting eggs this
is a morgan freeman impression yeah okay
no stop it
i love you
okay thank you morgan freeman
i don't know how to feel about that this
is the first time hearing of it i
haven't had time to process it yet ron
hoskins is going to be mario yeah bob
hospital
chris pratt is going to be mario no no
that's bad info that's bad info that's
better
it's bob hoskins
[Laughter]
that's crazy i'm going to have to look
into this man
i appreciate the heads up brother
mario's pet yoshi will be played by
richard heads up
i think she's gonna win a gold medal for
this role don't you uh i'm sorry is
there something i can help you with
business-wise well business-wise why do
you think they went with whoopi goldberg
for yoshi
they got whoopi goldberg to be yoshi
okay what is the world coming to don't
know if who would you put is yoshi i
don't even know what i don't even know
what that is it's a little dinosaur that
goes
[Music]
for a dinosaur mario's evil uncle
waluigi will be played by the legendary
actor al pacino
watch out mario because this is one
angry luigi can you believe they put al
pacino
as waluigi
thank you very much
this is a serious call al pacino as
waluigi you believe this donkey is that
you
no
oh okay have a good day please hold
while we connect your call to extension
two
what the hell is this music
[Music]
this is an orange tesla too
it's just a seven second loop
this
this is my punishment
for doing too many prank calls
hey can you put me back on hold i was
liking that music i'm sorry yeah sure
that's amazing watch out mario because
this is one explosive cast joe pesci
will play the character bob-omb in the
upcoming mario movie he's small enough
to fit into the cannons and you're going
to shoot him out he's a short fuse yeah
you piss him off
that's true all right well i will let
everybody here know
that joe pesci's making a comeback
thanks thank you for calling in feelings
right please hold while we connect you
to your extension
[Music]
for donkey kong we put seth rogen
because he looks a lot like donkey kong
well if i know i i don't even watch the
movies i hate hollywood come on you do
you know donkey kong though you know
donkey kong and you know yeah you know
it's not seth rogen oh definitely not i
would never pick him but who i would
pick i don't know maybe robert de niro i
hate robert
i'd pick the the only one may be
possible
you know maybe a rock
game zone just who i needed to talk to
i'm looking for a new game video it
features jack black
chris pratt
will smith
jack nicholson
morgan freeman whoopi goldberg al pacino
danny devito tom hanks
tom cruise samuel jackson leonardo
dicaprio brad pitt george clooney and
johnny depp it's called the mario movie
um
what was your question specifically
are you going to see it
most likely you can say
store hours
furniture cosmetics furniture sorry i
didn't hear that
furniture did you say cosmetics sonic's
nemesis dr robotnik will be played
i like donkey's raw reaction better
time to beat that
no i thought this was really fun
actually
uh what is this keemstar at denny's what
was that even
what did i do it's just such a weird i
love help from that
oh wow it is what it is
baby hey uh somebody donated 5 said i
was a paid actor denny's the night of
the incident i played the fart sent by
ab himself to frame ethan yeah that
makes me what the [ __ ]
well we know that a b mastermind did the
child saving so
he that that level of hygiene is not uh
beneath him sam donated five dollars
said hey there this is the ceo of
denny's
just want to say that ethan is banned in
all 50 states due to a fart incident
that burned a hole in the booth seat wow
that's spicy [ __ ] dude
what the [ __ ] is this keemstar's
breakfast sponsored by denny's
all-american breakfast at denny's
i farted in that mug
um there's some really good ones here
let's see
okay speaking of speaking of
keemstar
there was some
spicy we watched the dirty doms
video on friday
where he kind of just was like it's
david's fault
and keemstar is that he has the best
take he constantly has the best takes
when it comes to essay
roll it
myself you let me down she says haha
don't worry you'll be blessed with my
nail work one day wow now those text
messages
make it seem like there was consent
there right you know we don't know you
know a hundred percent if that's what
that means but it sounds like myself
dude this dude must be
done horrible things to be always
irrational taking this least
possible route to rationalize any essay
that ever happens on the internet she
texts him yeah let's do our nails
sometime and he goes proof of consent
right the proof of consent is there i
mean what
and then of course um uh deaf noodles
how many times do we have to teach you
this lesson old man
[Music]
yeah
pretty amazing stuff
oh this was actually really disturbing
since we're going down this rabbit hole
the same marketing girl that was in
dirty dom's video leaked
text message of natalie calling the
girls
the dumb essay [ __ ]
pretty amazing
in a bad way
okay don't be a snob they're admittedly
[ __ ] but that's the point no good girl
agrees
to
hit up with dom how else would he get
that [ __ ]
dude what a nasty what a
gross heart she has
man
david found the perfect like uh fall
girl
or not per but the perfect yes girl i
don't know
i miss the mark with that one
but the thing is like you know whatever
she says david thinks i mean i don't
think it's a stretch
so their thing is that she they were
[ __ ] so they deserved it
um
what did i say a name wrong baby
no i'm just saying they've been friends
oh yeah yeah
um
she says he needs to change and then
natalie says but he needs the dirty
girls because they party and do the
ratchet [ __ ] he needs for videos he
needs for videos
that was a david video not a dom video
good girls are boring he can't film you
and i we aren't content
dude she's [ __ ]
this is like some real lady macbeth [ __ ]
do you know what i mean like what
she said she went to the police too i
don't know but well i found that comment
really disturbing from natalie
there you have it
i i'm super i gotta say i guess i gotta
tip the beanie a little bit to trisha
who hasn't commented on this yet
i mean
can you do me a favor cam
um can you do the meme of that guy who's
like his face is bulging
but do trisha on it
yeah thank you
because she said she like she like
called off talking about people right
so when i saw this david and natalie
stuff coming up i was like oh my god
dude this is gonna be a real challenge
for her
and so far she i have to say she's
succeeding in that
so i guess that's a compliment to trisha
don't clip this and say i was talking
[ __ ] this is a compliment
i love it
kenneth copeland pretending to drink
blood
you want to see your new favorite video
oh you got my new favorite yeah it's
right here bike riders are [ __ ] wild
um
wow 100 000 likes let's go
why i've seen this
bro
like cattle i mean these people
dude your ass is getting
windshield wiped off the like a cartoon
that's what really gets me here
he's fully stopped
he's just staying there i'm assuming it
was so packed he couldn't
get out of the way without causing a
massive crash
but he didn't even break that's kind of
the beauty of it right
dude the windshield goes on the wind
wipers the rain wipers go on
the car is just trying to expel them
oh goodness great that is a great one
definitely
two dudes trying to sniff each other's
butt in public this is pretty epic oh
this is
this is wild this is is this safe for
life i think i mean i think so it's not
not really it's a butt sniff well
it's very similar to watch this now you
guys do
it's very similar to one that we watched
on the show previously of a guy and a
girl doing this in public where they
like oh
take a big whiff well let me ask you
this
there's no under the closed business
it's just a reach in and uh
that's fine yeah
i mean you can preview it before he puts
it on screen oh they're like best
friends this is i do this with my phone
yeah fair enough i don't see what's the
big deal they're just two homies with
blue shirts you dress up and you hang
out that's just normal [ __ ]
yeah this is what homies do i don't know
what's the big deal
oh my god
yeah
you guys don't do this with your homies
not lately
not during a pandemic
this is how we used to greet each other
back in
back in the day
someone saved me
yeah these guys are such homies they
dress in the same outfit yeah
they look the same
and also i like the the the
democratization of the sniffing of the
buttholes it's not like an alpha move
they both are scratching and sniffing
and that i think is beautiful
it's a true partnership
[Music]
is the dude on the left wearing a mask
we love that
masked king
he had to take him
down to get a good whiff right yeah no
he did okay
this sounds pretty funny twitch got
[ __ ] by their own dmca
oh yeah
it's just a clip
but you get these dmca's
metallica on their own song no way
so metallica is playing on twitch
well it was part of blizzcon
but this was on this is a clip from the
official twitch stream of blizzcon where
they had metallica play and this is if
you just play it and you'll see what
happens
wow what the [ __ ]
[Music]
wow
hardcore
that's rock and roll right there my
dudes
that's it that's what it is man
somebody pablo just down donated 20
australian dollars
said please play the fire safety video
it's been long enough
we can play it i mean
yeah
oh okay this is pretty weird but 20
dollar request here's cameron's i'm down
to watch it here's cameron's attempt at
the trish i was thinking
what do you guys think about this does
it work
[Laughter]
that's kind of the inverse for some
reason i was thinking her face would be
on his body right
i like this interpretation too though
yeah this is interesting
but i think it's more
yeah let's try the other way and see
which one we like better
that's interesting take for sure
uh you want to watch the fire safety
video
[Music]
i can't guarantee i'm going to laugh at
it i've seen that one so many times you
guys
fire
yeah it's true
maybe you're upset about being left out
of fan art what is this
this is some [ __ ] that's what this
is look at this [ __ ]
two weeks in a row
i see my beautiful co-workers and i'm
left out interesting observation even
love is prominently in both of them
which i love love
but now i feel the pain that zach felt
when i joined the show
so wait we've got ian
dan zach
this is me
yeah it's from this i mean eva's not in
it well this was this segment we did
where you were the love bot uh right
tesla
forgive me for recording
oh you weren't in the sketch
oh is that what happened how can you be
mad about that's a good explanation yeah
you weren't in the sketch
this is time repaid for pushing for
sketches this is this is it okay what
about the first one what's the excuse
for that
so this one is just like a kind of an
indie world type of situation let's see
that's me
and
ela yeah this one
wait is dan in this this is we're
missing something yeah that's me
so maybe there might be a possibility
that they posted two slides and i just
included one of them oh would that make
you feel better maybe don't try to make
me feel better i checked i've checked oh
you looked i looked [ __ ] i
went all over the internet huh
this is interesting
ian loves zach
me
wait i'm confused this is dan
no that's that's ian that's me okay
[Music]
hmm
do you want to talk about it
i made my piece
well i mean it doesn't seem like if you
want to bring it up on the show you put
it in the dock you wanted to bring it up
i brought it up privately and dan's like
we got to talk about that
did i
well this one i can't i can't really
back you up on because you weren't in
the sketch yeah i didn't realize that i
mean that one at least makes sense
but this one i feel the pain yeah it's
painful it hurts yeah
it doesn't see why that would sting i'm
sorry abe thank you zach
i i'll keep this in mind for future
founders no no love don't suppress don't
surprise now we have a whole
yeah we can't suppress good fan art
because a b is not in it i mean to be
fair you were actually in the last one
let me screenshot this
[Music]
by the way just it was a very good
depiction of maybe
here
[Music]
i mean this why i'm not in this one
maybe you don't hear me complaining
you are in it
i'm behind you
oh that's me i love that one
well dan's not in it and you don't hear
him complaining the disrespect
wait what are you talking about i am in
that ethan's the one that's not in there
oh you can sign in i'm confused who is
this that's me and who's this that's ian
so i'm not in this yeah i'm not in this
fan art i mean uh it's my show i should
be in every fan art right this is true
this is true how dare anyone make fan
art where i'm team rockets you should be
what's the main what's their their boss
giovanni or something giovanni
[Music]
oh no oh
how dare you come in front of me
on the day of h3 tv
complaining that you're not in the fana
here you're in the fan art and i'm not
it's my show i know it was you baby
you breaking my heart you broke my heart
you did i i am the show
you in the fan art without me
um
never go against the family
and now we're having a perfectly nice h3
tv
and what is this so now we've got to
return
yeah and now that i get to see fan art
without myself
huh
take it away
i can't see it it's too painful
in reality you guys got scammed
it's too painful maybe
you bring in front of me fan art without
me it's my show
hey look at the ice cream
abe you break them on
yeah so this one's better i think
this is trisha's face on the bulging
uh
veins this is a great meme i feel like
this is a great meme potentially
it's a little odd
they're shifting
valley it's a little odd you know
is there a way we can photoshop like the
eyes and and nose and and like
mouth separately to make it look
kind of more realistic i guess it would
be a serious project
you just dedicate your whole week yeah
just full time on that one please
drop everything
you breaking my [ __ ] heart there with
the fan art come on what are you doing
here huh you better get me the fan art
i'm at the heart of the show i better
face it of the show
and now you're in fan art without me
what are you gonna
forgive me don kleine
forgive me audience clicking the mouse
and papa's in the house
[Music]
hey be complaining about fan art
of one sketch he's not in
cameron adding all of the sketches
wait did you just make that cameron yes
he did oh that's [ __ ] good
think of the camera huh come on
can't redo that meme where i'm driving
your ass home after waiting for you to
edit those baby literally driving
cameron home
he's got a car now though so yeah god
bless that's funny
lots of drama back here huh
intense there's a tension back here man
stir in the pot
yo max donated ten dollars it's true i
was the seat cushion that ethan was
farting into
it was for sure him even his backside
has an impeccable hairline apparently
your hairline of your ass crackers i do
have a hairy ass i won't deny it
that's one hairline i won't try to deny
either yeah so this is a great i saw
this haul in oats a band
legendary band
apparently they did a show
where they had a 650 dollar vip
experience for mega fans of are you a
mega fan of hollow notes i am a mega
holo notes fan yeah you are i wouldn't
say i'm a mega fan but a fan what's one
of their big songs you kiss man
uh
well regardless apparently they're
classic but um
a split second okay
of one of their songs the chorus get the
chord uh what's the one one of my
favorite lyrics of all time is from all
an odd song it's i need a drinking
equipment you will recognize this within
like a split second [ __ ] deep bro
[Music]
okay i mean okay i see i needed that
[ __ ] so fast we literally but see off of
one second less than a second probably
that exactly right well apparently
people don't necessarily share
uh here we have a hold on we have an
update
a rich girl is another one too cameron
in the back a b driving cameron home
happy
i can assure you that's not how i look
you should see where kim's staying
what's wrong with where he's staying you
know what the [ __ ] it's sketchy
no it's it's
adventure it's an adventure each time
wait is he still in a sketchy part of
town yeah yeah okay but aren't you in a
temporary spot cam
no yeah but he's already claimed a gang
that bad huh
it's fun drop him off and hightail out
of there oh every time i literally
circled the block out there i circled
the block so i could exit a certain way
i've taken a moment three times that is
it that bad but it's pretty it's
probably one oh my god once
i'm sorry twice
oh eat [ __ ] cam how many times has that
driven you home
anyways this uh vip experience i know
it's a tension though can put up two
fingers like this for the record that's
[ __ ] nobody cares about how many
times zach's droven cameron home i mean
we believe you guys
whatever what are you guys doing i want
to flush this out what's this tension
here there's no tension why are you
imagine just wants to start some [ __ ]
hold on hold on are you upset that zach
didn't share the load of helping cam
commute more not specifically just zach
but
the squad could have helped out a little
bit
oh
oh for fun i'm coming wait hold on uh
dan this involves you now
if anyone should have been damned well
do you live near cam or something uh
maybe do you go closer to him i mean i
do not no i'm not that far from the
studio is the thing uh but i mean i just
made this as a goof i didn't want to
start an actual drama oh no okay no no
no but uh you've started it i've started
it i guess so we're in it uh but now we
dropped do you think ian should have
taken cam home more times
ian doesn't have i don't have a car
either man dude what could have kept him
ian's car broke and then sam's car broke
sam did you get your car fixed
yeah it's fixed okay thank god we've
given cam some rides yeah and i've given
ian a ride to the uh subway
once
all right thank you guys all right thank
you i think it's gonna cause the drama i
still love you cam i love you zach cam
you're the yoko owner of the 83 podcast
do you think dan could have given kmart
rides yes that'll work no i think dan's
atlas like i said he's juggling a
million things so zach was quick to
throw down under the wall it just seems
like dan is the closer one
to dude well dan's in the bathroom so
this is gonna be interesting too
no dan has stayed late in driven cam
even on saturday i think dan took him
home at like midnight so uh we're we've
gotten some consensus back here while
you're in the bathroom that you should
have given cam
more rides home
[Laughter]
what
what's the rationale
go ahead zach zach put the name forward
i was just joking i said you were good
all right uh you know what
everyone who gives a [ __ ]
oh cameron uh volunteered dan has driven
me back
during the sketchiest hours okay i
didn't know that um so he's out there
risking his neck
cam how can we get you into a part of
town where you don't aren't at risk of
bodily injury i mean
he's moving on the end of october okay
good
you found a spot already cameron
did you find a spot already
okay all right
he's working on it
um
so hauling oats
[Laughter]
so so here's the holland old 650
vip experience this is like a pre-show
kind of thing i'm assuming yeah
650 hall and oats vip experience
bro this is some sad sad [ __ ] they have
corn hole bruh they literally set up
cornhole for the vip people to entertain
themselves and in the comments like the
the persons that they sat in second row
and also paid for this so that was a
hefty uh ticket and 650. yeah
oh this was a separate fee yeah
i mean hey cornhole cornhole is a
premium game
dude did you see those finger sandwiches
let's take a look at what's to eat here
it's a few chunks of watermelon and a
little bit of pudding maybe
oh jesus okay i'm out
what happened
i don't know there's something with the
mouse track pad where i
touch it wrong and then i end up in a
weird bizarro
chuckle
hey somebody uh donated asking what you
think of the new coke zero what are your
thoughts
it's it's break can you could someone
bring me one
i mean it's so
[ __ ] good no we're nowhere near
there's a giant case of it sitting on
the counter dude the new coke zero is so
good like i i don't know how it's
possible that it it is closer and closer
these scientists are on the cutting edge
here i mean the amount of science thank
you a.b is this cold no it just arrived
okay that's fine the amount of science
and engineering that goes into making
this thing taste the way it does i mean
we could have saw global we could have
solved climate change by now for sure
this scientist works as hard on without
a doubt
it is magnificent
i think i i stand unanimous in that
right i'm a hundred percent with you i
was already a coke zero fan and and
you know
you can't taste the difference it's just
normal you know well i think it's your
life what do you say love we need a poll
on this
we need a poll okay yeah uh what is the
poll well what are we comparing it to
the oil coke zero or coke
yeah if the new or
old one is best the new okay so the new
is the new coke zero better than the old
coke zero
is there that many coke zero enthusiasts
in the chat is the new or just do a
third option i don't care about better
than the old
coke zero
yes no
this is hard hitting ethan farted in the
denny's [ __ ] you i never farted in
denny's bro you know that's just gonna
be the answer dude everyone's gonna
click that well we'll just
if you don't have an opinion on coke
zero
you know you can take the third option
which is ethan farted and denny's
coward
oh
almost eighty percent ethan
well i think that's hard no but as far
as the people answering the question
uh yes is winning
uh 14 to six percent
uh hard-hitting uh hard-hitting
market research here guys
what the [ __ ] am i looking at right now
the chew zone what is this
anytime you start magic happens
is it really that big of an event we
needed the whole thing
yeah it's a big deal it's a big part
chew zone come in and shoot down wow
my own crew
my own crew oh
enough
i come here slave away
i take care of you guys and now you're
coming at me with the children
no respect
no it was you fredo
you [ __ ] on the carpet this morning
somebody donated 45 british pound
sterling and said in what round of squid
game would ethan get eliminated
red light
yeah
for sure the first one i haven't seen it
yet so i don't know what that is it's
really i'm not done with it i'm on like
episode seven of nine god the last
episode i watched was so sad
i think you'd get to the honeycomb
which one was that i don't even know so
second round
let's see i mean
i guess when your life's on the line you
really step it up with the red green
light
i don't know i feel like i die in the
first round you die i love you but you
die i
no i agree
really cool um
netflix show though
those koreans think of the most [ __ ]
up ideas for shows man it's one of the
better shows i've seen in a long time
yeah it's a good one
so let's see copeland pretends to drink
blood the little honey meal this isn't
real is it
also uh
if you guys want to submit videos no
this is not real
it is real
the little hottie meal you better stop
this [ __ ] right now burger king this is
just pathetic
this is like
you can't
i won't allow this
yo 3 000 calories in this [ __ ]
yep
cameron said and i agree challenge
little huddy to eat his own meal
[Music]
3 000 calories you guys
oh my god i'm so not okay with this
do we have to try it on one but this is
just oh
please
please don't do that to me i mean you
don't have to eat the whole thing but i
will dan well we could just
cut you on a single bite off of it so
you could at least just try it
i think what makes it heavy is those
moth sticks i think it's the smoothie i
mean that's like easy seven like six
seven eight hundred it's gonna be i mean
it's gonna be all of it
it's it's a bowl of ranch cheese stick
fried chicken yeah it's everything's bad
here
yo i can't so let me get this straight
mcdonald's has bts meal
and
burger king has the [ __ ] little honey
meal ladies and gentlemen
you know what i gotta say
in defense i mean this is obviously
horrific
however
a lot of those mcdonald's meals that are
you know these sponsored mcdonald's
meals
one of our criticism of them is like
they're pretty much just like normal
meals i mean the bts one of these had
the special sauces my my point was just
like the star power
right but no absolutely a little honey
who the [ __ ] but what i'm giving them
credit for is at least this is like this
is like a well this is not like a normal
meal like the bts meal was just like a
coke i'm not that familiar with burger
king fries menu are we sure it's not
i mean they probably have mozzarella
sticks they definitely have smoothies
what is this sandwich
remember what was it travis scott and he
was it was just like a quarter pounder
with cheese and a sprite no i know
but i'm saying how do we know the
sandwich isn't on their menu
well it might be on their menu but i'm
still saying at least there's like some
pizzazz to this like there's a little oh
the little box
and mozzarella sticks instead of fries a
shake instead of a soda like this but
it's all on their menu
okay fair enough i i just think they it
seems like they tried a little bit
harder than the other i see what dan is
saying it's like how many people
actually go in and ask for this like
this is a this is obviously an actual
customer they literally just made a box
with brown text that says the chase
hudson meal it looks like doo doo text
but the food itself like how often do
people order these items like everyone
goes in and gets chicken nuggets like
the bts meal or everyone gets uh
mcdonald's there's no way anybody's
getting this hudson meal there's no way
i think it looks bomb dude i'll be real
with you it looks really good
i guess dude
all right let's get some chase hudson
meals in the that sandwich looks amazing
right now yeah that's what i'm talking
about
that's good that's good fika hello see
that's more than it won't have anything
sweet in there
can you guys
overnight it maybe
overnight you
can burger king meal to sweden we might
be able to actually like
overnight to sweden maybe like very
expensive
what's the questions you can do
fedex
because like
liquid
cooling containment
will cost like a thousand dollars love
but we cannot send this regularly i
lifted that away
just put in some dry ice i'm not trying
to kill you
yeah dude but if we actually if we cool
pack it and send it to you overnight it
could actually be safe to consume
yeah maybe
i just don't like the cheese
gonna be without the cheese no you eat
as it comes
no i didn't
they also have a nelly meal
but like aesthetically this page was
just
nelly like hot in here nelly like hot in
here nelly what it's a little smelly
meal it's just a little weird how
they're like trying so hard to
to walk they keep it real meal you
better stop this [ __ ] right [ __ ] now
cornell haynes jr parentheses nelly
wait
there's only three here
cornell is nelly oh who's this guy i
don't know who nelly is
what
the ghost
wait who's that on the far right like
hot in here
probably some other songs but mostly hot
in here
shake your tail feather
drop down and get your eagle on
yeah
all right let's get some yo
let's get some little huddies up in this
[ __ ] tell me you don't remember this on
wednesday i guess
yeah yeah i know it yeah nelly
it's getting hot in here so i'm gonna
make my own bk meal
it's a picture of a patty and a and
being cooked it's getting hot in here
so get your nelly meal if they didn't
take advantage of that they [ __ ] up
for sure
the ingram family channel sold an exact
replica of their newborn son what
wait this is a youtube channel
no
[ __ ] way
these family youtubers made a replica of
their son and sold it
[Music]
that's unhinged
oh you guys stopped the music okay
um this is
like
certifiably
[ __ ]
esme wanted to show you this was her
design that we showed you earlier and
with every baby
hey let's go to the website i'm
fascinated by this i really am get your
own baby reborn
i mean like
can't you just
oh 300
oh [ __ ] dude that's a 300 pounds
out of stock man 382
u.s it's a good deal
yo i mean so
first of all
the yeah there's a product description
at the bottom of the page pretty epic
first of all
what are people doing with this
okay
and
second of all
i'm afraid of this mom's obsession with
the baby like
like she's got these fake like when this
child grows up she's still gonna be
carrying around this baby like it's
demented it's [ __ ] sick bro
like there's these moms that are
obsessed with babies but they don't care
what happens after they become babies
you know
after they get older you mean yeah when
they grow up like three months later
yeah
i find that most of these um
they're called doulas they're like baby
specialists i mean they're really great
at what they do
we had one help us with theodore
but they a lot of them have these weird
infant newborn baby obsessions it just
it's very odd because they go i mean i
guess that's how you get into that
career
it's well suited for them but they go i
don't work with any baby over six months
it's just not it's like they need to be
around these new babies and once they
grow up they don't they can't do it
anymore
it's just like some
there's some condition there i feel like
that's not being like diagnosed
uh the jace river ingram
[Music]
that's true we should get one of these
for the no such thing as a coincidence
guy
uh the baby is based on jace at two
weeks old we have had the pleasure of
meeting him
in the store
the realistic adorable features allow
you to have your own little jace
his realistic soft touch skin and hair
are beautifully hand painted just for
you
he is unique life like reborn baby boy
with life weight doll exclusive
to
mary shortly
i can't believe 250 people bought this
thing
he arrives dressed in a powder blue
mocked baby girl
you also have the opportunity to bring
your baby jace reborn to specifically
organize baby jace meet and greets
oh they want these people to gather we
can't allow these people to gather in
one place
and but then you're the real baby jace
this lady is going to bring her real
baby jace there and you're going to have
to grow up knowing that there's freaks
the 250 replicas of you that do ungodly
things
from death to life
this group this at this group meeting is
strictly for new owners of baby jace
reborn
it's like a vip club for their family i
wonder if they'll have little
bowls of pudding there as well corn corn
soda you could play cornhole with your
baby jace
you know i'll have some haul notes
bumping this is not okay you guys this
is not okay to make a [ __ ] doll out
of your own baby
did they get criticism i see there's
down votes on it so
let's see
imagine finding out your mother sold 250
dolls of you as a baby to complete
strangers
imagine the horror when you're old
enough and realize your parents
replicated you in a doll form very
creepy and inappropriate to sell your
own child
okay this is just weird
yo
this is the weirdest [ __ ] i've ever seen
on youtube this vest with esme's design
printed onto it and this super cute cad
leaflet is that her other challenge
she's selling merchandise stuff with her
yeah sure we got a band family channel
oh no excited to be working with the
lovely mary shuttle on this beautiful
beautiful beautiful strictly limited
edition baby yeah you know what most
babies are limited edition one to one
right so some somebody donated said
peace and love ethan these babies are
usually for people who have a hard time
conceiving or grieving from miscarriages
yeah and i mean that's fine but that's
not what this is i'm not okay yeah
that's not what this is yeah thank you
for clarifying because i understand that
these are used to cope in some ways and
i'm not going to comment on the on the
medical uh validity of that okay but
this lady's selling a replica of her own
child that's what's weird about it yeah
all all the baby jace owners
like the fact that her fans are gonna
own a replica of her baby yeah you could
get a baby we don't need all the baby
jason owners to gather what are they
gonna talk about there
what are they going to get up to there i
don't know
[Music]
too much cornholing in one place
my gosh
this was made to represent jace when he
was two weeks old similar to the age in
the photo that you will receive on the
birth certificate if you buy one of
these beautiful baby j's dolls i can't
believe how like it
like it's so like him you look back on
the picture from when he last two weeks
old and it's like it's like exactly the
same especially when jason's got his hat
but you know this kid when he's like
grown up you're gonna walk in on his mom
and the mom is holding the baby jace
still with the baby jace
oh boy oh jesus
oh jesus
that's a [ __ ] interesting one eh
wild
oh there's a clearance on on ebay for a
new love bot
oh
what do you think about this love big
[ __ ] rules
check it out
[Music]
it reminds me of the robot from rocky iv
the greatest way we ever lived
you mean paulie's wife paulie's wife
yeah funny
that's crazy and lovebot's already
beating the [ __ ] out of us i'm afraid
with this one yeah after today i'm a
little
i'm a little uh reluctant to get maybe
you could do that from sweden i know how
sick would that be if we got him in like
a whole vr
rig and he just cruise around i mean
that's what this does
that would be pretty empty it's it's a
telepresence robot
we love that
is how much is it it's also 10 000. oh
[ __ ] prince ea's back oh my god yeah
wait how much is it 10 grand
we've spent more on dumber
have we
that would maybe be the record for
something i mean have we spent more on
dumber clothes
10 grand well your chair we were about
to drop like 12 on it oh but did you buy
it
i actually wanted to
here is it
do we have the link in the doc or you
sent it to me that's right
i think we i think we found the one
we're going to go with i'm going to pull
it up right now all right so dan's
shredder he's so funny
[Music]
i think we'll get our money's worth for
that box so
let's see
the drum roll please
drum roll
it's one that i mean it's not like a big
reveal we've looked at this one before
but we just did some research and it has
uh good ratings
it seems to be you want me to open it oh
yeah i got it right here yeah so the
scorpion the scorpion we're going with
right it's four grand
it can hold up to five monitors
which is sick dude this this is gonna be
awesome this is gonna be awesome yeah
yeah i'm excited the company seems legit
did you reach out or anything yeah we
did actually yes okay we've spoken to
them see we we checked how it shipped
there's not that much assembly we
thought maybe there would be because
this picture right here for that picture
i saw that and i was like you
[ __ ] i hope you got a wrench
because i would have been willing to do
it but no it kind of it comes like this
basically
um all folded up in a box
it seems kind of cheap if i'm being
honest um yeah but again a lot of money
but like that that's a four grand for a
chair is a lot of money i mean it's like
a [ __ ] mechanical scorpion bro
well it doesn't walk around or anything
it's not it's not that cool but um
but yeah i mean i found some uh it's
pretty exciting so i'm gonna be a big
moment found some legitimate product
reviews and everything um seems to seems
to work well this is going to be a big
moment it gives you there's a massage
built in
yeah it better be a [ __ ] process
during the show for that price
anyway so yes uh the scorpion uh is is
in the works it's finally exciting it's
finally happening please stand up it's
finally happening
i was totally willing to let you off the
hook like for for paying for this but
ethan ethan and sis so
please stay i'm gonna be hilarious i
agree i
i mean that would have been epic but it
really would have been unrealistic to
get it into this space i would have it
would have taken up essentially the
space of all four of us right now
yeah
so um
prince is back yeah or whatever
he's the look up guy he makes all these
like woke tech videos that are pretty
funny
yeah he ended up being like a pretty
cool guy right like i remember we looked
into him on the podcast years ago
and we decided he was we came out we we
decided prince eda was i
he made a video that was like all about
positive messages and stuff and we were
like this
this is that doesn't sound like
something i'd like
you did at the time i don't know maybe
you need to remember maybe you needed it
you needed it at that moment
all right well anyway woke bully shames
comedian
instantly regrets it and this is what i
think about your silly little joke
this is fake obviously
right i mean
you're being offensive
get off the stage
man
you've been booing the whole show
are you guys having a good time
guys
how dare you misgender us you know what
i work for the biggest media blog in
california and you sir
are cancelled oh is he like anti-cancer
culture guy now this is quite the term
for him yeah he didn't know he he went
to like
i
i'm amazed
i didn't know he was like part of the
like uh right wing name hole yeah
side note the guy on the right should
have been casted as the new mario
interesting
announcement coming soon oh are you
threatening me it's not a threat it's a
promise and this is what i think about
your stupid little joke
it's okay guys it's okay
she's she's a little tipsy
and i'm gonna turn this into a teachable
moment
see man i have a pet peeve when people
do videos like this and the audio is
like so obviously shot in a sound stage
like super crispy and it's just it
doesn't make sense he's in a stand up at
least shoot the audio there bro it just
it just it's uncanny it's unsettling to
hear the audio so crispy when you know
it shouldn't sound like that because
he's on stage can i get a man
amen brother you guys you guys know what
i'm saying brother yeah
thank you
back me up
you threw your drink on me
like a goof
and so out of all the languages in the
world tonight
i'm gonna speak
truth oh [ __ ] so you came to my show
disrespecting all night
but here's something you should know
just because you're triggered
doesn't mean you're right
damn
see you
[Music]
stand up
god what
stand the [ __ ] up dude i
maybe i'm just misremembering but i'd
swear when we like he was not a
right-wing media yeah it was not like
this like two three years ago
no
definitely not cancel culture people
don't fight fair
you call yourself woke but you're still
asleep
and causing nightmares
[Applause]
no
dude this guy sucks as a comedian by the
way he's not funny at all hey man it's
more like uh slam poetry than comedy
excuse me i am a hero fighting for
social justice
justice
here's the thing
let's call it for what it is
21st century bullying
[Music]
he went there i love that he's created
this whole fantasy
where he's the hero he made it up he
makes all the perfect statements
the perfect villain like this this
situation that apparently is happening
at every comedy club around the world
it just isn't like that i mean it's just
go to a comedy club every night and i
dare you to find the goof on this
oh where i'm being nice
oh auto corrects humanity yeah i mean we
don't have to do it right now but i was
just looking for it to reference it
later
2018 okay no i i i'm with you
i think we've
we're going we're going through a lot
with prince ie right yeah
you know
i think what we were saying was like
we were talking about how tech
is ruining people's brains and then we
were like yo prince i.e was a was ahead
of his time
right okay that was what it was
he's still a goon though look at what
look at his popped ass collar
trying to look like eddie murphy and
delirious yeah
see honestly that's your main policy you
bully someone online till they apologize
and then after they do you don't even
accept their apology
how dare you where is the manager you
know what we're out of here
no no no let's talk cancel culture
where are the jokes bro
is it supposed to be stand-up comedian
is the bouncer about to stop them from
leaving
bro these kidnapping is [ __ ] new
people now he's forcibly restraining
them right what you guys have sit down
shut the [ __ ] down
[Applause]
see all jokes aside i'm with you vicious
crimes like harvey weinstein and r kelly
are despicable and should be punished
for show
but for shout out somebody for giving an
opinion you don't like or telling a joke
or a tweet they wrote 10 years ago and
now their whole life is dismantled
man people are not netflix subscriptions
a human being
should not be canceled
clearly you lack compassion i mean what
if somebody reduced your whole life
story into one chapter
i guess i wouldn't like that
no way he got through to her
yo this was straight up made for
facebook it has 82 000 views here if you
go to facebook yeah i guarantee it has
like a hundred million views you're very
released
please prove me right with this
like
facebook would eat this [ __ ] up they're
like on facebook comments would be like
is this real they're like is this a
sketch or is this real i can't decide
i mean god forbid
so stop calling people out
how about you call them in oh
inside you're dealing with a lot of
anger because if you really want to
change behavior you wouldn't start a
fight
you'd start a conversation
you want to start a fight you would
start a
flight of stairs up into each other's
hearts
not to undermine but to understand that
person's conscious
see people can be rejected
i mean if the world met 20 year old maya
angelou it would have canceled her
because she was a known prostitute
jesus i don't like people no cancer for
being definitely not yeah i don't think
that's
maybe your friends i don't know i mean
do we cancel martin luther king erase
all of his achievements cause some
historians claim on his wife he cheated
no i don't think we cancel people for
cheating either also it's weird to go
from a prostitute to martin luther
well also like people are getting
canceled for like you know
r-wording people or and well he you know
to
not to defend princi
well he said like r kelly and harvey
weinstein those are monsters those
people deserve to be canceled well
clearly yeah but he's going like oh so
yeah i mean sure some cancellations are
dumb
i don't think anyone okay all right
princess do your [ __ ] thing tell the
unfunniest stand-up ever how about we
realize we all make mistakes and have
shadows
and the greater delight that shadow gets
bigger
everybody raise your glass if you wish
we lived in a world where we hated the
sin
not the sinner
see miss
the only thing we should cancel
is cancel culture and that's the truth
cancel cancel culture bro that's genius
i have never heard that [ __ ]
brilliant
how dumb do you feel now [ __ ] and if
you don't understand that
then the real joke
is on you
[Applause]
whoa her phone's blowing up that's my
time
wait what happened was she getting
harassed was she getting canceled
wait wait the castle culture just got
canceled
low love seeing hecklers get shot down
don't bother coming into work tomorrow
wait she literally got fired got fired
and he celebr this doesn't make sense
she just got cancelled
yeah
for being awoke as [ __ ] bee
don't bother coming into work tomorrow
wait i gotta read more of these i bet
this karen wishes she hadn't woke up
today
damn this comedian just pwned canceled
yeah it did oh boy wait i want to read
all of these
it has 2.1 million wait ben shapiro
hashtag cancel dead oh so you know
what you know who he's
watching what does that even mean she
got a message from ben shapiro oh yes
ben straight up as as harassing her
in the text messages
sending her skull and crossbones cancel
i'm gonna [ __ ] kill you
that's the best one
did you find it on facebook i found on
facebook uh it has 2.1 million views i
don't know if it'll allow you to open it
because i just had to log in like three
times
[ __ ] facebook sucked so much
i wasn't even able to find it okay 2.2
million i mean not as not as much as i
thought
but sometimes they people like repost it
on other pages and it get you know what
i mean
weird yeah i mean it's still relatively
new there's a lot of other videos that
have a crazy amount
uh somebody down here five dollars said
prince
is a conspiracy theorist he made a video
against sunscreen saying it doesn't
protect against the sun's skin can you
use coconut oil instead you know
that's such a weird one well that one's
actually been around for a while and i
haven't heard about that one in a while
that don't believe in sunscreen that's
so [ __ ] funny that's a very like uh
2015 conspiracy theory everybody's wait
i don't want to watch much harder [ __ ]
although i want to know if it's a video
or if you'll post about it yo what the
[ __ ] bro are you like like what are your
credentials to doubt sunscreen
coconut oil to prevent sun
here let's see how many the truth about
sunscreen
uh
let's i'm gonna read the comments on
this
coconut oil is definitely not sunscreen
though it has limited sun protection
i mean i don't i just don't think
coating yourself in oil and going out of
the sun that's like how you cook
yourself
if you want to lightly saute yourself
okay so the comments are actually saying
please stop spreading misinformation
people aren't buying it
someone said all good if you have
natural dark skin pale people would get
become a cooked lobster
now isn't it
i don't want to say this definitely at
all because i don't want to uh pull a
princier and
spread anti sunscreen misinformation
here but wasn't i
hearing in the last year or two that it
apparently it
if you go into the ocean with sunscreen
it's like it's bad for like coral reefs
or something it's bad out of the ocean
somehow what it's so i just remember i
don't know if it's uh if
that sounds like it's impossible to be
true because it's such a small amount no
here we go you have like this whole
[ __ ] tankers noaa
national ocean
national oceanic atmospheric
administration skin care uh skin care
chemicals and coral reefs yeah sunscreen
it's like contributing to coral reefs
getting uh
such a small amount of in the vastness
of the ocean
i have a hard time believing that i just
remember something in the back of my
head okay that's tickling that out
guys get up break out the coconut oil
yeah they have articles about reef safe
sunscreen so right yeah i remember
hearing about it
because all the coral reefs is it
coconut oil dying
it is not coconut oil is not protective
it only blocks out about twenty percent
so eighty percent still exposed it's not
recommended it's interesting that
oh olivia gave me a
little bit of center here common
chemicals used in thousands of products
to protect against harmful effects of
ultraviolet light threatened corals and
other marine life yeah guess so a
particular concern to scientists was
oxybenzone a chemical used in sunscreen
to protect our skin from damaging uv
light oxybenzone is bad news for coral
harming them by increasing a coral's
susceptibility to bleaching that's right
that's what what the [ __ ]
somebody believes
he's onto something
all right let's see what somebody tells
me he's uh taking a different route well
let's see if it's about maybe he's about
protecting the coral maybe he is maybe
he is let's see
what are you doing
i'm putting on sunscreen and don't give
me that didn't you hear johnson and
johnson took their sunscreen off the
market because it contains a toxic
chemical called benzene which causes
cancer
well it sounds like they took it off the
market
hey
dude he's trying to cancel sunscreen
[ __ ] [ __ ] yo cancel cancer
culture get this guy off the stage let's
sit send this guy's death threats and
text messages bent shapiro send this man
a death threat in the text
really yeah i mean isn't it ironic a
product designed to prevent you from
getting skin cancer has ingredients that
cause skin cancer
damn
here just use coconut oil
coconut oil is a natural lotion used for
thousands of years it'll protect you for
45 minutes of sun exposure see your skin
absorbs everything you put on it so if
you wouldn't eat it why put it on your
skin wow bro that is so dumb what do you
will you you eat the ground i mean your
feet touch the ground what does that
mean
your skin is to protect your internal
organs [ __ ] [ __ ] idiot
like you never you drink bath do you
drink pool water
yo everything that touch my skin i
consume bro
do you drink ocean water
why put it on your skin wow this is one
of the dumbest things i ever heard wow
how do you know all that well because i
follow prince ea
wow
damn no no no how do you know that
it was almost an interesting question
uh it does look like johnson johnson
recalled uh
sunscreen because of some cancer-causing
uh chemical though yeah but like you
said they recalled it
right they took it off the market
right yeah so i'm just saying that that
wasn't out of the blue that claim that
he was saying in that video
i
just found an article about it wow and
hawaii has been certain sunscreens to
have two certain chemicals you know
maybe he's onto something with this oh
stop it that's all i'm saying
well
i mean that screen is great you guys
please wear something yeah wear
sunscreen i mean there's so many things
though that you know could potentially
cause cancer i mean yeah that's true i
mean the air we breathe
right
let's start there
yep
yeah anyway um
olivia says there are oxy benzoni
benzone free sunscreens right yeah oh i
just found out trisha saw her that we
were mentioned her briefly in this
podcast and i got a photo of her right
now
so
got a little glimpse over there
moses actually sent me that photo
no way
how long we've been going there's a lot
here uh three hours oh wow and we it's
oh it's late yeah we should probably
wrap it up is there anything good here
that i shouldn't skip over
oh wait patrice wilson is a religious
anti-vaxx trump guy
mr
just bringing back the classics oh yeah
bringing back all the classics
i'm scared to talk about him he i
actually was
i'm not gonna lie this [ __ ] i
was afraid for my life for the first
time
i literally when he did that countdown
and like was showing pictures of me and
[ __ ] i literally went to a parking lot
and got out of my house
wow well the countdown hit zero i mean
understandably that was so long ago now
i bet you a lot of people watch the pod
now uh
i didn't watch back then and aren't even
aware of that whole song but way back in
december i don't really want to kick the
hornet's nest with him
this guy's on his own journey you know
what i mean i i don't i don't want to i
don't want to pile on him i think it's
that was probably the funniest i've left
as a fan watching that episode it was
terrifying i mean yeah because i could
tell you guys are sincerely scared i
don't know why it was well just the fact
that we like
discovered it in real time yeah and like
it was there was the curtains
i was doing a podcast a live podcast
with post malone
patrice wilson he made
friday and by rebecca black you guys
remember that and a bunch of other
really questionable you know what
patrice i'm not even gonna patrice
be with go with god
love his love baby go with god i don't
want to be a part of your story anymore
i don't want that heat bro
and he's like super jacked too
he's like massive bro
god be like steroids in that man's
system who would win the fight chat or
patrice patrice would murder chet
he would tear him to limb we got we got
a decent amount of old heads saying they
remember that episode it was one of the
best episodes ever it really was it was
just
it was alive and raw and wild
and terrifying
it's scary
let me see
for people that haven't seen it i kind
of want to tell people what episode
number it was you could pull it up
i don't mind
you got the episode number well anyway
oh here let me pull up the highlight
yeah
roll it
oh my god our highlights you stick
kids so much views three million
well this one has post in it
okay okay good i'm glad okay this is
long but he did a countdown
and he put my name h3h3 in it and then
he kept doing all these weird subliminal
things calling me out
and then while it was live he cut to
like this we look at this [ __ ] it was
like blair witch project [ __ ] yeah like
walking this is like [ __ ] horror
movies
why is he going to church is that a
church
who's buried in that house and then he
was like cutting to a shower curtain
that kept moving like someone was behind
it and anyway when the video came out
when the when the countdown expired oh
yeah this was super weird look at this
but yeah i guess you're right
why what the [ __ ] dude do i close this i
mean yes oh i saw a hand i saw a hand
i saw patrice's hand it was a boy i told
you he was going to cut it off didn't i
it'll be back
he changed did he change the font okay
i'm not i wasn't
yeah so when this expired me and ela
actually left the house
yeah understandable
it was funny i remember at first you
were like you didn't seem too afraid of
it and then like as it went on
progressively you're like oh [ __ ] this
is kind of yeah no i i i got more and
more afraid for sure
but you know what i wish patrice well i
don't wish any harm on him i don't wish
i don't hope anyone goes and bothers him
he's reinventing himself as a [ __ ]
and uh anti-vaxxed trump guy and he's go
with god bro just live your dream have
fun with that yeah have fun with that i
wish you all the best
episode 39 it looks like of the podcast
we stopped even numbering i don't know
we must we've done like how many
episodes we've done now we've been doing
for a week gotta be hundreds and
hundreds we haven't stopped numbering
but we've
done all these yeah
i mean
you can pretty easily see how many uh
videos are on our channel
when i started a year ago right after
200 so
oh we've blown past 300 easily by now
yeah we probably blew past it without
even realizing
so uh are any of these worth going in on
i don't want to miss anything good
body armor demonstration
man that was whatever
wild chiropractor
i think we made sure
anthony master gets carried out of
grocery store like a rag doll sounds
[ __ ] awesome
people won't learn
these people
did you look at the girl beating up the
mannequins with christmas trees no let's
watch that because this is actually a
sequel we've we've watched some of this
girl's content on the show before and
she popped up on my feet again oh for
real yeah
friends of the show
sort of
oh this is the girl who farts on them
yes oh yeah she's awesome
she's got a whole new genre oh just
christmas tree violence
she's just i think what she's preparing
to defend herself around christmas time
i guess i guess where there's christmas
trees all over the sidewalk
in case santa claus comes in without
permission right
this was gonna
happen need to know what she's preparing
for someone said
this girl is great man
i'm surprised she's gonna finish with
farting on their face though
yeah that was a big theme in the last
one um
she's moved on from that i guess thank
you zach
all right guys well it's been a long
show hope you all had fun
we will be back on thursday
with
off the rails we're gonna make you
having some little honey meals it sounds
like 3 000 calories to the dome right
you will be happy to hear about that
and um
and then friday and then sunday oh
oh on discord what do you want me to say
guys
just shout out uh
people a lot of these videos were
submitted by people okay so you can do
that on our discord there's a channel
for submissions h3 tv submissions
yeah thank you to everyone from discord
who submitted these videos the names are
here i forgot to read them i'm sorry
guys i'll i'll do better next time
i don't know how to go back to the mark
with that one yeah i missed the mark
but thank you guys for submitting
and uh hope you enjoyed
and we'll see you on uh
thursday for no members
uh
love y'all
see you next time peace
[Music]
my
[Music]
you